uh we have a heavy load at this point in
time just to start off i' tell you that
we have um I figured out what we would
need in terms of additional days after
next week and four days and I've asked
us them to specifically tell us what
four days we have so that we can finish
our work we probably have a day and a
half of hearings but we do need time to
exact the bills and and exact
them
[Music]
does not make for good legislation
anyway I'm required to read a script
this morning as chair of the house
Judiciary Committee I find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing of bills referred to the
Judiciary Committee executive session on
pending legislation may be held please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 it's
271-3600 or email HCS
l.st do. us that's HCS leg. State
do.
Us in the event that the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled we do have one staff member
who is participating with us today
that's Jennifer for our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during the meeting will
be done by roll call vote we're going to
begin the meeting as we are required to
do by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states their presence please
also State whether there's anyone in the
room with you during the meeting which
is required under the right to no law
and I'll begin by saying I'm Edward
Gordon I'm here and I'm at my Brick
House in downtown Bristol and my wife
times and and Mr clerk would you call
the
represent
right represented
Belmont
is6
uh representative Alex um good morning
um here in gwn my roommates are in and
out of the room representative
Bry I'm home in Hudson with grown kids
coming in and
out representative
silver I'm here at in Guilford my home
office by myself except for my
dog representative green I'm here in my
home office in Hudson with my
wife
Kelly not
hi I'm here in um Temple just the dog
and
Trier representative Trier
he indicated that he would be here later
morning repres Smith here in Durham
alone representative bur I'm here in
West Milan with Siri and Alexa but
that's
it representative
deeno uh present I'm here in New Market
in my home office and my husband's
roaming around the house representative
Chase
Rollinsford with my crazy
Kenny representative Langley here in
Manchester and my husband is here
representative
MC I'm in um alone in my Portsmouth
office representative Pig I'm in exor
home office with family in the
house I'm repr organ he skip me on the
list so I'm here home alone in Durham as
usual
so representative
Simpson good morning I'm here in exitor
and my sons and husband may be in and
room
you all
set
that th up he there our first bill this
high
Frozen in the brick I'm frozen oh you're
open thought out good now you're can you
hear me now yes thank you our first bill
this morning is House Bill 108
FN uh relative to minutes and decisions
in non-public sessions under the right
to no law the primary sponsor is
representative ulery
and representative UL are
to I think I'm unmuted am I
you thank you thank you for the record
my name is Jordan oler Hillsboro 37
Hudson and pelum New Hampshire this is a
relatively simple bill regarding
non-public session
and requires keeping of a list of what
these are and Publishing that list as so
that individuals know what the public
body did and why they did it it doesn't
interfere in the privacy of the
non-public session other
than as to the purpose of the non-public
session so it's it's relatively simple
uh it's just to tack on to the the
existing law but what it does do is it
does
uh shine a little bit of light into this
what the public body was doing at the
time they uh decided to go into public
session uh you can read the thing uh
it's legally and two sentences or three
sentences
so and that also allows the public body
at a later date if necessary which they
can do now to make the uh Records public
should that be uh required because
of Shifting sands on which a public body
operates I'll be happy to answer any
questions if there are any questions
about from the committee thank you Mr
chair yes representative Oregan um
pretty well serve a simple question
though it not sure what answer might not
be so clear what exctly problem does
this solve do you have any maybe you
give us some example something that has
happened that was a problem but which
wouldn't have been a problem if we'd had
this law in place it helps them it helps
eliminate a lot of quote conspiracy
theory that's the common term I don't
like it but uh that develops the board
was doing this the board was doing that
it you know it shines a sterilizing ray
of sunshine into the operations of a
public body and just makes it more clear
to everyone in involved as to what was
going on and why it was going on I I
mean it people understand Personnel
issues they understand that they can
back away and uh that some of the stuff
needs to be done uh in private as as
well it should be uh that's not a
question it also enables the public body
if there are uh reasons that uh they
need to be to uh make the the minutes or
decisions available for public discl
disclosure uh uh as uh circumstances
dictate uh around a particular thing uh
it would
um for example down here in Hudson as uh
several of your board members know
there's a huge project going on um
before the planning board if the
planning board were to go into private
session as we almost did nonpublic
session uh because of a Personnel issue
uh that would then mean that that would
be put in the docket as that the board
did this and then when the inevitable
loss it uh it arises as it probably will
um that's an aside uh then we can say
yeah we did and this was the purpose of
it and
that it just protects everyone involved
and it makes it crystal clear that no
one was hiding nothing from
nobody to use the
vacular right
thanks thank you um and representative
svet did you have a question yes thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative gy for taking my
question um I like the uh the
transparency that this bill would
provide uh along constitutional
requirement under uh part 1 article 8
but then there is is the other side of
this uh looking at the Constitution and
uh an unfunded mandate a new unfunded
mandate regarding uh part first article
28a can you uh give me an idea of what
your thoughts are on the balance of
those two constitutional
issues uh thank you representative Silva
I don't see an article 28a issue in here
because the board is already required to
keep a set of minutes all this is is
minutes
are you all set represent syia all set
wper so part of this bill is about U
maintaining this list
and is it already required that to go
into nonpublic the board has to
Inu State the reason why they're going
into
nonpublic yes they do and all this does
is uh add to that declaration as to uh
that we're going into nonpublic uh for a
um particular reason
uh then minutes of that nonpublic
session are kept and they're kept
aren't I have a follow I need to put
this in so if you if I may Mr chair I'll
two there any other questions for
representative
ery seeing
none thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chair members of
the committee kind of wish was up there
in the
L yeah thank you uh the next person who
signed sign up to speak uh in opposition
gra good good morning hopefully you can
hear me all right we can thank you my
name is n Grace I am a I'm representing
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
this morning uh we are opposed to this
bill um because we think that this bill
would end up essentially creating a lot
of work on the part of
municipalities without having any real
tangible
benefit um a couple problems that we see
here is that the list is ongoing and it
justes and the bill doesn't provide for
anything to ever be
removed so in 20 years you're going to
have a gigantic list in every
municipality and it's going to list
every uh
possible uh every reason that some board
entered non-public session and then
left and you know 20 years later a lot
of that's not going to be really
relevant because it'll be something like
either purchasing a property in which
case those minutes will have been
released a long time ago and everyone
will have known whether or not the Town
Hall New Town Hall was built or
not or it'll be something like a uh an
item sealed for reputation purposes so
for example uh someone
applied for municipal welfare or had
something involving Municipal
welfare happen and that was discussed at
the board level um and that would be
sealed forever um so you're going to
have this really long list that doesn't
really serve a a
purpose um the second reason is it
doesn't really seem to assist the public
uh because you know if the Public's
interested in whatever the matter is
before the board and then the board goes
into non-public session members of the
public who are interested in that will
presumably be paying attention and
understand you know the board went into
nonpublic session and then they can make
the request at a later point in time to
unseal those minutes and as this
committee knows essentially what would
happen is the the member of the public
would come in make the right to know
request uh the the board would get that
request of valate it determine whether
it's appropriate to unseal the minutes
and give the minutes
over um having the list of minutes
doesn't really help facilitate that or
or help speed up the process um it just
kind of creates a list so if at some
point in time someone in the future
wants to look and see you know how many
times uh for instance the select board
went into non-public session to discuss
a reputation issue um they now have a
list of those things so those are really
our two
Gray
chairman many of us most of us maybe
don't go to these meetings
and don't f close attention to the
minutes but my question really
is without a list of the nonpublic
session how could I for example Lear my
if I have some concern over what my
select is
doing and there's no list with nonpublic
session how can I find
out when they went in why without going
week after week after week minutes by
so presumably you're concerned about
specific item so I guess if I can use an
example here um you know let's say
there's some sort of uh employee related
issue you're concerned about how the
select board is interacting with let's
say the police
chief um when you go and make the right
to know request you're not you're
probably not going to make the request
for all nonpublic
because the select board could enter
non-public session for all manner of
manner of items they could you know as I
said be building a new or considering
building a new uh Town Hall there could
be discussions about um you know a whole
bunch of things when you make the
request you have to reasonably describe
what you want uh pursuant to the law now
so what you're going to say is you want
all minutes related to you know uh the
the select boards interaction with the
police chief over the past year for
instance and whoever is reviewing the
minutes is going to
see that there's both some things in the
public session and there's going to be
something presumably in the non-public
session and the board would then have to
evaluate whether to release those
minutes or not um so they still have
this obligation to go back and make a
reasonable search through the minutes
and that's in the law now um to to
determine that they're going to be
complying with whatever your request is
as the requester so um this wouldn't
change that they still have that
search any followup representative oper
set
are there any other questions for Mr
Grace seean thank you for your testimony
today thank you Mr Cher the next speaker
is uh
available and I don't see him on the
Bolton and I do see him on the list
Bolton good morning Mr chairman thank
you I'm the City attorney in Nash New
Hampshire and uh it strikes me that this
U piece of
legislation uh just requires a separate
list of information that's already
available uh since a body has to be in
public session to uh take a vote to go
into non-public session and the publicly
available minutes will uh show who made
the motion to go into non-public session
the specific provision of law under
which
the motion is
made uh subsequently when the non-public
session ends if there is a vote to keep
the minutes
confidential that motion has to be made
in public and has to be noted in the
public minutes so it seems to me the
list required by this uh piece of
legislation is uh simply redundant adds
to the paperwork burden that the
selectman secretary or some uh
clerical uh employee has to
maintain and it's hard for me to imagine
the uh problem that it's
solving so thank
you thank you are there any questions
for Mr
Bolton seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you and I did see
green can you hear
us hello Miss
unmute this green we see your name on
our screen but we don't
ah okay here we go there thank you for
your patience um I uh wasn't intending
to testify on this bill today but I am a
member of right to know New Hampshire
and I would like to jump in here um I
think if anyone were to ask a sitting
selectman or a school of board member
how many non-public minutes they have
they would not have any idea and as a
result they never go back in unseal
minutes that should have been
unsealed so in in administration a list
would help a great deal to advance
transparency because right now in my
experience many public bodies have a
huge Legacy of sealed public minutes
that do not need to be sealed but simply
don't remember them and a list would
help the public remind the elected
officials that they need to go back and
review and unseal sealed minutes so I
think this is a very important bill for
transparency and to help the public
Administration thank
you thank you are there any questions
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony Miss
green thank you and is there anyone else
who wishes to testify if you do you need
hand seeing none we'll close the hearing
on House Bill
108 and we have about three or four
minutes
before I just know
that uh there
were 15 people who signed up and offered
their support for the bill and six
people who signed up and indicated their
bill
Mr chairman I have a problem my computer
at the moment take five minutes see if I
can figure
see
while you're doing that I
and representative bur indicated I had
indicated that representative Burch
would
um provide a parliamentary inquiry on
cac10 if it was taken off the consent
calendar as unlikely as that may be but
he may not be
available for our session next week and
so if you could give some thought as to
who might be able to replace him that
would be helpful to me so I can get that
today is there anyone who wishes to step
up
I'm sorry I didn't hear what you said Mr
chairman I was running back into the
room did you ask us a question yeah well
sort sort of
uh representative uh representative
Burch indicated that he would not be
able to do the Parliamentary inquiry on
cac10 CA cacr 10 is on the consent
calendar
and I don't know of
any effort at all to take it off
calendar but if a parliamentary inquiry
should be necessary I'm looking for
someone just to replace him the
Parliamentary inquiry so I can give that
name to the
volunteers Mr chair I just want to say
this is representative McBeth I am not
attending the sessions next week I I do
want to be an active part and I would
like to volunteer but until I get my
vaccinations I'm I'm not going to be
attending so put me on the list for
later thank
you just Mr CH Mr chair I since I spoke
uh against
ccr10 uh I'd be uh honored to do a pi if
necessary okay representative silver
thank you very much for stepping up I
appreciate
that that solves a problem for me thank
you
all and representative wper where do you
how are you doing almost back you're
back
[Music]
no well yeah not I'm not in the meeting
am I well you are in the meeting but
you're in the meeting by virtue of being
I just have tojin
distance are are you able to let us
since we can see you and hear you are we
able to go forward with our hearing y
okay our next bill this
206 that's a bill relative to collecting
bargaining agreement strategy
discussions under the right to no
law the primary sponsor of that bill is
representative turky
tury and is representative turot
available to introduce the
bill if you could just raise your hand
[Music]
helpful
turot I am here can you hear me we can
good you can you can good morning you
ready yeah well good morning everybody
um members of the Judiciary Committee a
special shout out to my former
seatmate uh Miss McBeth how are
you haven't seen you in a while so good
to see you you too uh my name is len
turkot I represent straford County
District 4 which is the town of
barington I bring before the committee
today
hb26 uh which is about one thing and one
thing only and that is
transparency uh before I get into the uh
reasons for the bill I want to give you
a little bit of background on myself
um regarding uh my experience in
negotiations I've been a member of the
Allied Pilots Association for almost 36
years now and that's a union that
represents
14,500 uh Pilots of American Airlines
and during that time I spent almost
eight years in various leadership roles
at the national level including a board
of uh Board of director position several
committee chair position and the most
applicable to this issue I spent two
years as a full-time
negotiator and almost the entire uh rest
of my time at 8 paa involved with uh
negotiations and with the interpretation
and defense of our section one of our
contract our contract is a very detailed
one it's almost 450 pages in length and
the section that I was uh pretty much
the expert in section one is uh along
with its supplements and the the pages
itself is almost 75 pages in length so
I've negotiated opposite the management
of the world's largest Airlines for many
many years so I'm very ex very familiar
with the negotiation process and
environment uh this bill would re this
bill would require negotiation sessions
to be open to the public but would still
allow caucus sessions by one side to be
done in close sessions since negotiating
goals strategies and tactics should be
confidential collective bargaining
agreements je uh generally represent one
of the single largest cost items to all
public employers and therefore uh to the
taxpayers of the cities counties and
state collective bargaining agreements
also control many aspects of the union
members pay benefit and quality of work
life from the New Hampshire taxpayers
perspective the first time they ever get
to see the impact of a CBA is when their
tax bill arrives and you will
undoubtedly hear testimony today that
says the taxpayer is the ultimate
Authority they can vote the employer
represent uh Representatives out
unfortunately that's not a very very
realistic
argument and one meant to dissuade
negotiations in public unfortunately by
the time the taxpayers see their annual
taxpayers uh tax bill it's too late to
have any input to those responsible for
representing their interests at the
bargaining table from the union members
side of things currently the New
Hampshire public employees normally get
to see the final package after the
tenative agreement has been signed off
on with open negotiations the union
members could now be made aware prior to
the agreement being finalized possibly
allowing input to their Union reps
officers well in advance of the tenative
agreement just as the taxpayers would
have the ability to have their input
prior to the agreement so with the union
membership in previous hearings on this
subject there's been testimony submitted
that suggests that open negotiations
would have a NE negative impact on the
process and I believe this suggestion uh
suggestion to be uh what I would call a
fear grenade to scare members of this
body to object to the to the
bill I I pulled a few comments out of
the previous testimony just so I
could I guess maybe anticipate a little
what what you may hear
later during a public heing on a similar
Bill a Mr John kooy of the AFS CME who I
do not know in testim submitted
testimony stated quote I'll be blunt
there's a lot of arguing and yelling and
quote he went on further to say quote
opening negotiations to the public would
stifle this type of give and take and
thereby dras drastically curbing both
sides ability to reach a resolution in a
timely fashion if at all end
quote I'm I'm I'm hoping that Mr Cy does
doesn't really believe arguing and
yelling are a required or necessary part
of a negotiation and if he does maybe
putting negotiations in public View you
would actually create maybe a little bit
more of a civil environment in my many
years of NE negotiations I have never
once uh witnessed arguing and yelling
have I seen emotions run High yeah uh
but I've also seen fiery emotions during
debates on the state house floor yet the
public gallery has been witnessed to
this and I'm pretty sure they handled it
just
fine have I seen pre-planned tactical
actions by one side or another that
might involve slamming and olders and
walking out in Mass sure I've been part
of that but the suggestion that
potential temper outbursts are a reason
to suppress transparen he just doesn't
hold the
water additionally the public
negotiations might have the effect of
actually tempering either side's
expectations this could convince both
sides to open initial negotiations and
continuing negotiations with more
realistic proposals by starting with the
realistic proposals the result could be
the shortening of the time required to
find finalize a new contract this would
lead to lower cost for both sides
especially for the public employers and
taxpayers another argument put forth by
Mr cloy previously was the need for
secrecy otherwise it would prevent or
hinder open discussion of sensitive
items of an individual employee nature
but these particular instances relating
to individuals can certainly be handled
without identifying the person by name
in a generic sense historically
Grievances and arbitrations are normally
handled confidentially outside the
contract negotiations Arena so those do
not need to be part of public
negotiations and I have been involved
with many many many arbitrations dealing
with individuals that have been settled
without going making them public it's
just another argument that doesn't hold
water we have transparency for the
public embedded in nearly every public
process selectman meetings planning
board meetings public hearing on pending
Les legislations as we are doing right
here right now and floor debates and
voting in the legislative Chambers you
will certainly hear the opposition today
pull the pins and toss many fear
grenades into the room excuses as to why
this can't be
done I just don't believe that and I
believe those who were going to argue
against it uh may just have something
they they they want to continue to keep
hidden from the public Okay so you could
just wrap up yeah I've got one more
quick thing and I will be done um I've
included a couple of reports they were
sent to you last night um I will also
send copies of this uh testimony to you
when I'm finished today and the last
thing I want to conclude my testim uh
testimony with the preamble to the State
of Washington's open public meetings act
which reads quote the people of the
state do not yield their sovereignty to
the agencies which serve them the people
in delegating Authority do not give
their public servants the right to
decide what is good for the people to
know and what is not good for them to
know the people insist on remaining
informed so that they may retain control
over the instruments they have created
and quotes thank you very much I will
send you this testimony I'd be open to
any questions thank you are there any
turet seeing none thank you thank you
for your
testimony I note that we have have eight
people who've signed up to speak uh only
one of which asked to have more than
three minutes so I'm just going to limit
the speakers at this point in time do
about three minutes each um
and we'll call upon Donna green to
testimony thank you can you hear me we
can yes thank you thank you um good
morning Mr chairman and committee
members um I am president of the school
district governance Association of New
Hampshire we are a private organization
whose mission is to give voters a voice
by empowering elected School District
officials to reclaim control over
budgets and curricula in addition to
offering seminars and webinars to
educate and inform Schoolboard and
budget committee members we have a
legislative agenda of increasing
transparency in the budgeting and
Collective bar bargain process in school
districts this is the second time we
have attempted this bill it passed the
senate in 2018 and we are grateful to
representative turot and the other
sponsors for working to advance it
again this changed to the right to no
law is not a radical proposal nor is it
anti-union as of 2018 15 states do not
have any exemptions from their open
meeting laws for Public Employee
collective bargaining in other words 15
States government employees and public
public I personally became convinced of
the need for public view of negotiations
during my own experience as a school
board member on our District's
negotiating team it was evident to me
that the behavior I observed from my own
team would be unlikely to occur in
public furthermore the public I believed
probably assumes a lot more high-powered
facts and arguments then ultimately
ensued pulling back the curtain of
secrecy from all this would hold our
elected representatives to Greater
accountability and also give union
members a much better understanding of
how well their team is working on their
behalf based on my experience I believe
both sides would be surprised some
people object to public negotiations by
asserting that compromises can't be
forged in public to them I ask what
kinds of compromis are you forging that
requires secrecy with public
money in this time of great social
unrest because of mistrust of public
institutions I would respectfully
suggest that it is incumbent on you to
require the most transparency possible
in the conduct of government Affairs
especially where the majority of our
taxpayer dollars are spent and for sadly
diminishing results as the law stands
now if both sides agree on negotiating
in public they may do so if the taxpayer
Representatives request open
negotiations but the union
Representatives do not an old PE ruling
requires both parties to conduct
negotiations in private this is why we
are asking you to change the law to
require both parties to do the right
thing making negotiations public will
give both pres represented parties more
insight into how their interests are
being represented in advanced with
better accountability for eled officials
and Union leadership Miss green
your yes your three minutes or thank you
thank you very much yes representative
green you need to
unmute there I'm this representative
orgon here my question is um we've heard
a lot of I about the teachers unions as
something distinct from the uh from the
teacher you know the Educators as a
whole which doesn't seem to exist in
other Industries because like um like
for example R Turk his experience he his
organization was the voice of the of the
pilots collectively so I so why is it
that the uh to why is it that the uh
teachers unions are are sort of become
sort of a separate entity at least in
some people's eyes including the
governors from the uh from the you know
the from teachers in general and do you
think uh you think that's more and and
um do you think there's a and also what
was a problem you had with you seem be
dissatisfied the school school boards
negotiators what what was uh what was
the problem there too so those that's my
question you may not have much of an may
not know the answer to it but I'll ask
it anyway
thanks yes representative Horgan um I
don't I don't have the same perception
as you do that the teachers are separate
from the unions I I don't have that
perception so I can't answer that
question um with respect to my own
experience um I thought my team was
needlessly provocative and
hostile um and and I did not feel it was
productive and I thought that people
would have uh objected to that kind of
behavior had it been conducted in public
and rightly so okay yeah okay I
understand thank you any other questions
from Miss
Green see none thank you for your
testimony today thank you Stephen
[Music]
Bolton you raise your hand we can pick
Bolton thank you Mr chairman you able to
hear me now we are thank you I'm the
City attorney in
NASA uh and as such I'm involved in many
of the uh collective bargaining
negotiations with our various employee
groups uh have been
for uh nearly 40 years now in one
capacity or
another um what this uh legislation
seeks to do obviously is to have the
negotiation sessions uh themselves uh
open to the
public uh but the strategy
sessions uh can still be in a a
non-meeting uh environment without the
need to allow uh the public uh to
observe and without the requirements of
notice and minutes uh but the
negotiation sessions themselves would be
subject to all of those requirements
that is the public allowed to ATT 10
minutes would be required to be
kept
uh and made
available
uh I think this have the potential of
leading to protracted negotiations I
think both sides particularly the union
side uh would be discouraged from
exploring ing potential
Alternatives that they fear may not be
uh immediately popular and sometimes the
hypothetical scenarios that eventually
lead to compromise uh if they are not
explored uh will result in negotiations
going on for a much longer
time in every case the cost items of uh
a tenative agreement have to be
submitted to the legislative body so in
towns and most school districts that's
the town meeting or or School District
meeting in cities it might be the board
of Alman or city
council at that time the terms of all of
the contracts the C that provide for
Appropriations that is any cost those
are made public and the public has the
opportunity to uh vote on on them or let
their representatives uh know how they
feel so I think there's much less
secrecy uh than has been
suggested uh because everything that's
going to be
costly is disclosed before the agreement
becomes finalized but I do think the way
negotiations are conducted with joint
sessions with an negotiation takes place
and then uh frequent breaks where each
side uh caucuses and explores what the
next move is going to be uh I think
having that be subject to notice
requirements and The Taking of minutes
when you do go into
negotiations is going to complicate and
elongate the
process think it would be U thank you
I'll just wrap up it think this was uh
not solved the intended problem and
caused more problems than it solved
thank you thank you attorney Bolton are
bolmer no okay uh thank you for your
testimony
today yes
me representative wper did you have a
question
yes
I oh good
grief okay is that
better that should have fix
that all right so
uh what my question first question and
this is for Mr Bon and for you for me
you
I don't know Mr Bolen could you
understand the question I could not I'm
sorry yeah I'm sorry representative W
but we I don't think we understood your
testimony I I still didn't quite get it
he asked if you submitted written
testimony I did
not thank you for taking my question and
Mr chairman I would appreciate it if you
would ask that question when speakers
begin
okay thank you thank
bar you could raise your hand if you're
in
attendance I do not see Miss Barrett
will come back to her
next person is David
Hampshire hello can you hear me we can
Mr sad thank you um my name is David sad
I live in rumney New Hampshire I am
president of right to know New
Hampshire uh currently the way the law
is written uh it allows all discussions
um of negotiations to be done in what's
called a non- meeting and per the right
to no law uh a non- meeting does not
require notice be given minutes be
published or in any way inform the
public about the collective bargaining
negotiations so the whole process is
essentially done in secret um the
previous testimony has outlined a lot of
reasons why um it should at least is far
as the negotiations part of it be no
longer considered a non- meeting and
instead be made part of a public meeting
um and I won't rehash U those points um
I would like to put emphasis on the fact
that when public bodies and unions meet
to negotiate a collective bargaining
agreement the people in the room and not
representing themselves the public body
is representing the taxpayers and they
Union is representing the union
members however the taxpayers in the
union members are not allowed to be
present during the
negotiations so how does
either representative group know how
well their representatives performed on
their
behalf how much did each side give up
and what did they get in return they
don't know but they should know uh
transparency is
required uh uh union members uh and
taxpayers alike need to be able to
determine how well their representatives
performed their
duties only those not working to provide
full benefit to their respective group
would feel threatened by having
negotiations open to public scrutiny the
idea that negotiations must be done in
secret to save face or to somehow give
people the ability to speak freely in my
opinion is just a smoke screen excuse
for saying I won't be able to justify to
the people I represent the positions I
took during the
negotiations um so I
think the there there's going to be a
lot of uh testimony both for and against
this bill um but I believe that there's
a
balancing test that that that should
take place similar to when people are
asking for records and and information
that some want to keep uh uh private in
in and away from public scrutiny and
that is you have to look at the overall
benefit because there are arguments to
be made on both sides and you can take
um depending upon your position you can
agree with both
sides but in the end you you have a
choice is it public or is it not public
and I think when you balance both
sides uh you'll find that there's a
greater uh benefit to the public and the
taxpayers by having it in uh the public
sad if you could just finish up I would
appreciate yeah then having it remain uh
secret uh thank you very much and I'll
represent Horgan do you have a
question you need to unmute again might
be useful um yes Mr sad um of course
these um the terms of the contract are
eventually made public so why why do we
need to change make this small change to
the law when there is already the
Safeguard the fact that officials you
know either uh Union negotiators who
negotiate bad contracts will probably
pretty can be fired by their membership
since these organizations are uh those
organizations are generally pretty small
deed Democratic and also even it's a
little bit harder with the public bodies
but they're all appointed or elected for
uh limited terms so like why what why
why do we need this remedy in addition
to the obvious remedy that somebody
negotiates a really bad contract can be
uh costed out of either the public body
or the union negotiating committee as
the case may
be well a lot of Times Union contracts
of course their obligation and many
times those obligations span multiple
Years and we're talking also significant
amounts of money uh so by the time the
taxpayers find out yes they can vote the
public officials out of office that they
felt did a poor job but long after the
public officials are gone the
obligations they've committed their
taxpayers to remain and so I think it's
more important that the taxpayers be
involved earli in the process so they
can stop the check from getting written
in the first place as a opposed to
living with the payments and the tax
obligations for many many years okay all
right
thanks uh are there any other questions
for Mr sad Mr sad I I think you already
submitted testimony on this did you not
yes I did and I also want to say I did
try to connect on the HB 108 I must have
had some technical difficulties uh you
um notice that I was on but I will I
will will submit um additional comments
um for 108 thank
you okay the next person to testify is
Brian
will good morning Mr real good morning
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Brian R and I serve
as the president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire and I'm a
captain for the Portsmouth Fire
Department
the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire is a state Association
representing 42 local unions and
approximately 2,000 active and retired
professional firefighters and paramedics
across the granite state I'm providing
testimony and opposition of hb26 this
morning as a longtime representative of
Labor I am intimately familiar with the
collective bargaining process and have
been a part of many contract
negotiations throughout my career the
intent of collective bargaining is to
create a har harmonious working
relationship ship between labor and
management and to identify the interests
and expectations of all parties in order
to reach fair and Equitable
resolutions it is difficult to
understand what the true intent of hb26
is on its surface it would appear that
the intent is to make the collective
bargaining process more
transparent however the current
mechanisms in place already allow for
full
transparency currently in New Hampshire
cities and towns are required to provide
details surrounding all public employees
negotiations prior to any vote on the
matter in sb2 towns this means a town
meeting consisting of a deliberative
session which calls for explanation
discussion debate and amendments to a
pro a proposed contract followed by a
voting session where the voters have an
opportunity to make the final decision
on said contract in non sb2 towns there
is a public session where the details of
a contract are shared and the public has
afforded the opportunity and a public
hearing to weigh in this is a process
that has been successful for many years
which leads me to believe that if
transparency is the true intent of this
bill we are searching for a solution to
a problem that doesn't exist the
suggestion that the public does not have
input on this process prior to receiving
their tax bill is simply misleading to
the members of this this
committee what seems more likely is that
the intent of this bill is to dilute the
collective bargaining process in an
attempt to stall negotiations and make
it more difficult to reach fair and
Equitable
agreements this not only damages the
Integrity of collective bargaining but
it is disingenuous to the New Hampshire
taxpayer negotiations are meant to
resolve issues in a way that both
parties find acceptable and to do this
in a way that is Swift and efficient by
creating an environment where there is
an audience during negotiations neither
side will feel comfortable speaking
candidly on an issue and worse you will
encourage grandstanding and the sharing
of exaggerated or misleading information
that that uh is intended to earn public
support this delays a timely resolution
which translates to additional costs to
the public the result of passing this
bill is really quite simple in spite of
its likely intended effect it does not
negatively impact any party involved in
the collective bargaining process the
unintended consequence of this bill will
be an increased cost to the New
Hampshire taxpayer by drawing out an
already extensive process this is not a
quote unquote fear grenade this is Mr if
you could finish up appreciate it very
good thank you members of the committee
uh it's for these reasons that I
respectfully asked this committee to
oppose
hp26 happy to answer any questions you
may have did you sub have you submitted
that testimony yes sir uh I have
submitted additional comments and
written testimony thank you other
questions for Mr will yes representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr real for taking my question
um that last part you um mentioned that
it's an increased cost for taxpayers I'm
just wondering the bill doesn't have a
fiscal note I'm wondering if you can
kind of um explain that a little more
for me yes thank you for your questions
uh representative um The increased cost
that I'm referring to uh obviously uh
City and town negotiators um are
compensated for their time and efforts
in the collective bargaining process uh
as our Union officials when they're
brought to the table um to negotiate a
contract for those that they represent
uh the the longer we extend out this
process um the more compensation this
means for those members additionally uh
it does not allow for uh municipalities
to um move forward with the negotiating
process which uh could potentially lead
to decreased costs for uh health
insurance for instance so um both sides
want to reach an agreement because both
sides uh want fair and equitable
results um and uh that that means from
the municipalities perspective when they
are negotiating they're looking for
decreased costs whether it's health
insurance or other benefits and the
longer we extend this process the less
likely they're able to do
that um thank you you any other
questions from Mr
real seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you very much next
yes hello Mr beton Court good morning
I'm Don beton cour from snipe I'm a New
York New Hampshire small business owner
a longtime resident and chaired sonap
budget advisory committee a few years
ago ago I believe that requiring
transparency and negotiations with sunap
teachers union is the only way to avoid
closing some or all of sunap public
schools in the near future according to
New Hampshire doe sunap already has the
highest cost per pupil for districts
offering K through 12 and its Middle
School number one at
30583 per pupil is almost twice the
state average of
15,938 by comparison Plymouth State
University charges
23,450 per pupil including instate
tuition plus an unlimited meal plan and
a shared dorm room sunap has reached
these outrageous cost levels after two
decades of declining enrollment coupled
with secret contract negotiations
between a St strong teachers union and
compliant school board members the vast
majority with family members either
employed by or enrolled in the schools
three years ago we put this petition
waren article on the March 2018 ballot
should the contract negotiations between
the cipy Teachers Association ation
teachers union and the sunti school
board be conducted in public session so
that both the teachers and the taxpayers
can observe how their interests are
being
represented um the yes votes Prevail by
a 65 to 35% margin the school board
completely ignored the vote and
addressed it only when pressured six
months later in September the chair
claimed to be reading a statement
verbatim from the board's attorney
stating that public negotiations would
be illegal a subsequent right to no
request for a copy of the letter was
rejected on grounds of attorney client
privilege and negotiations were lat
later conducted in total secrecy last
month anticipating another round of
contract negotiations next fall 51
voters signed a petition warrant article
for the March ballot it began by
repeating the 2018 wording the 65% yes
result and the board's choice to ignore
it and negotiate in secret it then asked
should the sunap school board request
that the upcoming teachers contract
negoti iations be conducted in public
session and if the teachers union
refuses to negotiate in public session
then negotiations will not occur and the
current contract will continue in place
until a transparent negotiation process
can be mutually agreed upon at Senate
pce February 1st school deliberative
session the teachers union demanded that
the above wording be entirely deleted
and the article amended to read should
the Senate School Board conduct
negotiations with the sun Teachers
Association in a manner consistent with
the law including but limited RSA 273a
and RSA
91a the school moderator ruled that the
amendment to be was out of order because
it changed the subject of the petitioned
article but the angry mob attending in
person overruled the moderator this
meaningless one- sentence question will
appear on the ballot the teachers union
successfully eliminated the voter's
option to vote on op for open NE
negotiations I encourage you to pass HP
206 so that voters will be able to
observe how school boards deal with this
type of teachers union bull in during
contract negotiations thank you thank
you Mr beton Court are there any
questions for Mr beton
Court thank you for staying in your
three
GRS
Grace could you raise your hand if
there thank
you thank you Mr chair my name is n gra
I represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association um I don't want to be
needlessly duplicative so I will just
state that attorney Bolton and Captain R
summarized much of what I wanted to say
uh in their testimony the only things I
will add um is that from our our
perspective you know we work with all
234 cities and towns in New Hampshire
and we know that uh from experience that
when Public Employee compensation is
being debated it's often the employees
who fill the room at town meeting and we
imagine the same thing would happen if
negotiation would be open to the public
um even if it's the case that it would
be ordinary towns people it would
certainly be the the most uh interested
in the negotiations and the problem with
that is as those two prior uh speakers
stated is it makes it very performative
you know each side is trying
to continue to gather the support from
their members and the people they think
support them and so they're less likely
to come to a compromise romise and
obviously the entire purpose of the
negotiation is to come to a compromise
in a setting where that's
feasible uh one of the other concerns
that we would have is because this would
remove the negotiation session from a
the non- meeting status there are a
couple things that may happen here the
first is that uh you'd have this
constant back and forth uh where the
public body would have to open or en
close uh you know the session um they
need to adjourn in order to to go to
their caucus I.E their strategy session
and then
reconvene and there would obviously be
some sort
of there would obviously be difficulties
um as as they try to do this and also do
uh the
negotiation um the other thing is is
it's possible that
by changing the law and the way that
this bill proposes um you would have
more instances of negotiation between
one select board member or one School
Board member and you know the the school
attorney or select board attorney and
you know the whoever the administrator
is so the Town Administrator or town
manager and um School Board
superintendent with the union and
obviously you can't have a
a board of one so again these instances
would not be subject to the right to no
law at all and you'd have the same issue
essentially that this uh that this bill
is trying to do away with and it would
just shift the way in which these these
things occur and exclude more members of
the public body from the negotiation
process R if you could finish up it
would be appreciated I'm finished Mr
chair are there any questions for Mr
Grays yes representative Horgan um yes
one of the I mean one of the one of the
differences between the employee side
and the public body side is the
employer's livelihood is at stake so but
so de
members do de member municipalities find
that it's uh significantly harder to
retain and retain public employees and
hire new ones when you have relatively
generous compensation package as opposed
to those who are doing what the
proponents bills want to do who
um certainly I imagine that uh
individual employees are more likely to
stay with employers who pay them more
than other employers and to seek out
those
opportunities oh great
thanks hey thank you for your testimony
today did H you submitted written
testimony I did not but I can
okay um are you going
to uh I will do so Mr chair thank
you Eric power p r if you're out there
[Music]
hand I do not see Mr power but there are
U those are all the people who signed up
in advance of today's hearing I see we
do have a couple of hands up for people
to
morning we are not hearing you
Mr chair did you call on me yes we did
bill okay you had your okay I'm sorry
you had your hand up yes I did for HB um
216 but I I came in when this was still
going on so I'm
sorry I'll testify now if you want no
that's okay thank you Becky Wilson did
206 good morning yes I just want I won't
take up much of your time uh Mr chair
and members of the committee my name is
Becky Wilson I'm the director of
governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school boards Association um I
believe that um our executive director
Barrett Christina has submitted written
testimony to the full committee I know
you had been looking for him earlier but
he's been pulled away unexpectedly so I
just wanted to make sure that the
members of the committee were in receipt
of that testimony um and if not you will
be getting it shortly I just wanted to
make sure you weren't looking for him
unnecessarily okay thank you very much
day thank you and the last person to
hello Mr Durkin hello Mr chairman thank
you very much uh again for the record
Jim Durkin here on behalf of 4,000 New
Hampshire ask me Council 93 members and
before I begin I I just want to note
that the gentleman who sponsored this
legislation quoted extensively from our
Union's testimony against his bill in
the last session and while we're uh
delighted we made such a strong
impression I I must point out for the
record that the remarks he quoted were
in fact delivered by by me not John kooy
as he repeatedly stated uh never
nevertheless we stand behind those
remarks and we're here to restate a lot
of them today look I spent a great deal
of time talking to ask me leaders and
staff who spend a considerable amount of
time at the negotiating table and I've
also spoken in confidence to the people
who sit at the other side of the table
and suffice to say this is one of those
rare instances where both management and
labor are an agreement the overwhelming
consensus is this legislation if
approved would have a chilling and
detrimental impact on the negotiation
process and moreover both sides believe
it would unnecessarily lengthen the
collective bargaining process and any
agreement that might be reached would
ultimately be less beneficial to both
sides and and look we can see why this
might be difficult to understand for
people who haven't been part of a
contract negotiation session and for
those who have experience in the arena
the reasons for opposing public
negotiations are are almost intuitive
but let me try to articulate a few uh
despite what the bill sponsor said
negoti iations particularly prolonged
negotiations are often heated and there
is a great deal of Spirited debate but
people say what needs to be said and
they do so because they're uninhibited
and know they're working with and
against people who understand this is an
important part of the process opening
negotiations to the public would stifle
this type of give and take and curb our
ability to reach a resolution in a
timely fashion if at all and you know
another more concrete drawback would be
this the strong reluctance for either
party to raise specific personal
examples that might be driving a
discussion uh one side might want to
propose a new sick leave time policy
that was driven by health conditions of
a specific employee and in order to be
able to effectively advocate for that
policy one would want to be able to
discuss the situation or situations
driving that proposal and and that would
be extremely difficult if not impossible
without revealing even a bit of
information that could ultimately lead
to someone's privacy being violated in a
in a public forum which in turn could
lead to Legal AC action and the same
could be said for discussions focused on
disciplinary procedures but it might be
these very specific examples that need
to be raised in order to have an
effective discussion that will lead to a
binding agreement these are just a
couple of examples but suffice to say a
significant portion of the the process
is driven by prior disputes between both
parties and in order for productive
negotiations to continue both parties
need to be able to discuss these
disputes openly and frankly without fear
in closing look if committee members
looking simply to safeguard the interest
of the taxpayers through this
legislation I would point out what has
already been stated there are various
laws and processes in place that provide
the taxpayer with ultimate approval over
contracts that are negotiated and
finally of course as you all know
taxpayers have a say at the voting booth
they have the ability to elect their
leaders and Empower these individuals to
negotiate on their behalf it's a system
that's worked well and continues to work
well and I thank you for your time and
and and getting me into
testify
any questions for Mr
Durkin seeing none thank you very much
for your testimony today thank you sir I
see no I see no other hands up and we're
we and I just note for the record that
there were 22 people who signed up in
support of the bill and 14 people who
signed up in opposition to the
bill
and we'll I think we'll move on to House
Bill
216 there are just five people who have
signed up to speak on
216 but given our time constraints we
limit the testimony to three minutes
this morning as we have on the other
Bill House Bill 3 16 is relative to
public notice of and access to meetings
under the right to no law primary
sponsor is representative Weber and is
tesy if you are if you could raise your
be yes thank
you good morning representative Weber
good morning Mr chairman and committee
members I uh for the record my name is
Lucy Weber I represent cheser o district
one the Connecticut River towns of
Hinsdale Chesterfield West merland and
Walpole and I spent my first three terms
on this committee so it's good to be
home um the bill today simply allows the
provisions of the governor's emergency
orders regarding remote meetings to
survive the pandemic and continue on uh
so that uh public bodies can use them
and operate under them once the state of
emergency has been lifted so in that
they will be very familiar to you
because they're the rules essentially
that we have all been operating under um
I have two motivations for bringing this
one is that uh various select board
members have been heard to say that they
really would like to be able to continue
to operate remotely or in a hybrid form
after the
pandemic um and uh secondly I had the
experience of chairing the house Health
and Human Services oversight committee
which meets on a Friday and has never in
person uh when I was there had more than
the members of the committee uh the
members of the department who were
coming to testify in front of us and
possibly one or two members of the
legisl or the public there uh but
certainly not more uh but after these
Provisions went in I realized that I had
31 participants available and several of
them uh contacted me afterward about
issues that were raised during that
meeting that were important to them uh
and they were able to do so because they
could participate uh listen in from
their offices without having to take an
entire half a day to get to ConEd and
listened to the meeting so I I think
that's healthy and I'd like to preserve
it so uh the goals of the bill are to
promote greater access um by the public
and greater participation by the public
when participation is
appropriate um greater ease and access
of participation by members of the
public body um and that would allow more
people the option to participate uh in
public dialogue
and um my intent also was to make the
bill permissive rather than mandatory
because my goal is to make things easier
on a public body not harder and so I
wanted each public body to be able to
determine what conditions and situations
worked best for that body um so I I
really truly wanted each body to be able
to choose what fits for them
uh I have had some discussion from with
Mr Grace from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and I understand
that he has an amendment that he will be
submitting oh and I'm sorry I forgot to
state that I don't have written
testimony but
um
the with respect to Mr Gray's amendment
I wrote the Bill so that if remote
testimony or remote participation was
offered to a board member it also had to
to be offered to members of the public
so because that just seemed to me to be
fair uh but Mr Grace has some um
realistic and important concerns about
uh
connectivity Broadband access all kinds
of issues for boards and so I think his
um Amendment says that if there is a a
physical location for the meeting they
do not have to offer the other type of
public access and I will just say that I
will leave that entirely up to the
wisdom of the committee uh I am open to
any amendment that um helps us move this
legislation forward and I thank you for
your time thank you very much and are
Weber seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you sir and
representative Porter you are now
on thank you Mr chair are you hearing me
we are thank you it's weird to speak and
not have my face there um thank you for
taking my testimony for the record my
name is marjerie Porter I represent
Hillsboro district one the towns of
antram Hillsboro and Windsor and I'm
here in support um of this bill um I'm
married to the chair of the local
planning board and since probably around
um the end of April planning board
meetings have been being held in our
home office um and it's been quite an
experience um it took a while for them
to establish a system and for all of
them to feel comfortable but now sitting
there with him I can hear that the
meetings move move smoothly some of the
benefits that representative Weber
mentioned in her testimony I've seen
firsthand um it would be L they would be
lucky the planning board would be lucky
to have two or three members of the the
public in attendance at their meetings
when they were in a public um building
but now they the list is quite long this
is increased um civic participation here
in Hillsboro and it has kept people up
to dat on issues that they're concerned
about being present at the meeting has
helped that um they've not had to cancel
a meeting for bad weather um which
causes a problem as you know in we
scheduling um it's helpful for elderly
people who don't get out much at night
with their driving difficult and also
for young families who might have to
hire a babysitter if they were to go out
to a meeting I just see that this
process is a is a good one and I'd like
to see them be able to keep doing it um
when God help us this pandemic is over
and we're back to more of a normal uh
type of life so for those reasons I'll
I'm supporting the bill and I would be
glad to take questions and thank you
representative Alexander do you have a
question um I do Mr chair um thank you
representative Porter for taking my
question um I'm my question is around um
towns that have sb2 that are sb2 towns
that have um Town deliberate session and
town meetings how would this Bill affect
that um would they be able to vote
remotely um in those
situations I don't know representative
Alexander I don't know how that um HS
through I I know our school district is
sb2 and um they held their deliberative
session in person in the gym at the high
school
um so they didn't do a remote meeting at
all and I don't think that this bill
requires them to hold a remote meeting
and the voting will be in March just
like every other town meeting
event any other questions for
representative
Porter seeing none thank you for your
sad
okay Mr sad yep can you hear me we
can thank you uh my name is David sad I
live in rumney New Hampshire and I am
president of right to know New Hampshire
and right to know generally supports any
effort to make meetings more open and
transparent and the arguments mentioned
earlier about greater civic
participation is something we welcome um
however as the bill is currently written
we are opposed to it and uh the reason
for that is we feel this bill does not
provide sufficient saf guards to ensure
the use of electronic meetings does not
violate the Public's right to observe
and listen contemporaneously to all
public
meetings um we technology is is a very
good thing it uh Zoom meetings and other
Technologies um are very beneficial but
it is technology and and it can cause
problems and it can also be used to
subvert The public's U right to know we
would support uh this bill uh if it was
amended to address several
shortcomings uh that we feel exist uh
number one we think meetings held
electronically and without a physical
location should only be allowed during
emergencies or a state of
emergency uh two if during the meeting a
member of the public notifies the public
body that there are problems with access
those problems must be stated in the
minutes and if it is verified that
problems with access existed then all
actions taken during that portion of the
meeting should be null and
void um and three if the mechanism of
public access to the meeting is capable
of recording the meeting at nominal cost
then the public body shall record the
meeting as a public record
the minutes for the meeting shall
indicate that the meeting was recorded
and the recording is available to the
public these changes are needed to
address potential problems created by
the use of various electronic
Technologies when conducting meetings um
and I'll give you a couple of examples
uh in when you meet in public in a
physical
location um uh the you know technology
isn't going to get in the way of that
that individual um being able to
contemporary contemporaneously uh
observe the meeting uh technology uh
problems can exist and this can be
unintentional or intentional uh I've had
people contact our group where they've
mentioned they've attended a public
meeting through zoom and they were put
in a waiting room uh and they were kept
in that waiting room till long after the
public meeting had already started
started um I had people contact us and
tell us about a situation where uh they
even though there was public input uh uh
available uh the individual controlling
muting and unmuting uh muted individuals
uh inappropriately uh and these are just
you know problems that exist with the
technology so uh while we we look at
this as a good thing uh when you look at
all of the pausal uh positive scenarios
I asked the commission to think about
some of the problems that can exist with
uh the technology and make sure that you
amend this bill to address some of those
problems for example uh comments and
chat can take place Zoom as a technology
allows there to be comments and chat is
those comments in chat that take place
are those going to be public records and
available for public disclosure
sad yeah uh and then um also you know
lack of uh disability accommodations as
well so those are some things that uh I
hope you will consider in amending this
bill I did provide written testimony
along with the suggested amended
language that uh if adopted we would
support thank you thank you Mr sad and
representative Horan did you have a
question oh sure yes my uh first
question is um I know certainly this
institution in the Hampshire house did
not
routinely record committee meetings
until uh till the pandemic um and that's
probably that's probably created more
more more access so is that a you find
that other bodies
uh don't routinely record the uh record
you know make video and audio recordings
of the meetings and also or or or we
so were we were we unusual in being like
behind the curve and doing that sort of
thing or is that like a uh I want to say
pendemic problem that sounds like
pandemic is that a common problem with
um other other public bodies that you
follow uh I I think a lot of times they
don't uh they certainly don't make the
the the the meetings uh available by
default um a as the house does I mean
some do some don't but again there's no
requirement in the language of the right
to know law to make the recordings uh
available the only requirement is that
available follow up thank you Mr chair
and um there's also a j just as a long
time M the house I've often in the past
had difficulty figuring out what it was
we did even sometimes when I was in the
room just just because of uh the nature
of the type of minutes that we kept but
the uh other thing is
um how do you think how do you think the
operation of the house and other public
bodies will be affected by the fact that
you have um you think we have a broader
or narrower base I know certainly with
you're an example of the right to know
issues there's a uh we have a pretty
like a group of frequent flyers
including yourselves who follow the
issue closely keep track of when all the
KN when all the hearings are going to be
have a lot of like institutional memory
and now we have more people going into
that so is that uh you think that's a uh
you think that's you think that's a good
thing or or a bad thing and um how how
do we uh going forward how do we how do
we uh continue to broaden the base of
the members of the public who actually
follow these meetings and observe it
just because you know it's become I
think a little bit simpler for somebody
who's not quite as intimately involved
in the issue is as you are Mr sad to
like find out when the hearing is and
what they need to do to sign on so kind
of a Rand question I there's a question
in there
somewhere I I think it's a very good
thing to have remote uh remote meetings
and to you know and I'll use zoom as an
example although there's multiple
technologies that are being employed uh
you know it is going to increase civic
participation um uh and I think if you
require that the meeting recorded and
that recording be made a public record
that goes a long way to not only
increasing civic participation but it
goes a long way in making sure that if
there are any technical difficulties
that are encountered during meetings
those will the the recording will uh
help identify those and will allow
people to use that as a way to get their
public bodies to address those technical
difficulties so that they don't continue
to occur and and and make sure that
people uh don't abuse some of the
features of the technology to limit
participation that's the concern that we
have is make sure you amend the language
to ensure that possible abuses of the
technology don't occur all right thanks
all my all I had to ask thank you Mr s
and Mr chair representative
syvia thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question Mr sad um of all of
the uh reports that you've had have you
had any reports of meetings having to be
adjourned because of Technology
problems uh no and that's and that's
part of the problem uh you know we have
this requirement that says oh there's a
number to call if there's a technical
problem um and you can call it I'll give
you an example uh on hb18 I had a
technical problem and I called that
phone number and I said I'm having a
problem and I got a you know I forgot
who the person was but you know they
they certainly didn't resolve the issue
by getting me in touch with the
chairperson so that I could during
testimony being open I could offer my
testimony on 108 so you know it's all
after the fact and of course I don't
know when that message is going to find
their way to the the the chairperson in
your in your committee but it was long
after the discussion and testimony had
been closed so fortunately I'm able to
submit you know written testimony and
and comments after the fact so I'm sure
you'll still get that that input but
during a regular meeting um somebody has
a technical problem they call into that
number and there's no nothing in the law
that's going to say that the meeting is
going to stop they're going to resolve
the issue so that person can be
reconnected or whatever and and the
meeting is going to continue to resume
at that point and I'm not saying that
should be done but according to the
amendment we put forth you know we want
to make sure that any technical problems
that are identified get recorded in the
minutes so that helps um res make sure
the problem does get resolved even if
it's after the
fact thank you representative Chase did
you have a question uh yes I do thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned about the chat
rooms and was that something that would
be made available because people do tend
to just go off on their own tangents
there there are ways of not having that
on if you see we don't have it there's
no way for us to chat with each other if
that were um just always noted in a
public hearing would that be something
that you would
support uh yes um I'm talking that the
technology does allow for chat the bill
as it's currently written would not
prohibit the use of chat um and it it
also wouldn't prohibit the the
submission of comments as well and so
I'm just saying the language of the bill
while it it replicates the governor's
State uh of emergency order um there's
some loopholes that uh from have to be
addressed in this bill to make sure that
there isn't communication that takes
place among members or between the
public and members of the public body
records okay thank you yeah any other
questions for Mr
sad seeing none thank you for your
testimony
Grace hi Mr Grace hello Mr chair uh
thank you for allowing me to speak again
I represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association um a couple things I would
like to address and then the proposed
amendment that I sent to all of you
yesterday um first I wanted to point out
that RSA 33 hyphen a colon 3 hyphen a um
does state within its body that if there
is a recording made of a public
meeting it needs only be kept until the
minutes created after which it could be
destroyed and it that recording would be
subject to a right to no request and it
would be subject to that request for uh
as long as that recording exists
regardless of whether the minutes have
been created or not um and secondly
since the committee brought up the
technical problem issue um that's
obviously that's obviously a big
issue um the way we have interpreted the
emergency order is that if the technical
problem
uh is a problem for everyone not just
one person trying to connect that's when
the uh body would be required to adjourn
so you know if I'm trying to dial into a
meeting and it's just my phone or my
zoom connection that's a problem um the
the body doesn't have to do anything but
uh if it's you know 12 people and all 12
people can't connect um you know then
then there's a problem at that point the
theard would have to adjourn so that's I
just want to let you know what our
interpretation was there um as far as
the amendment goes I believe that uh the
sponsor summarized it uh quite well um
we would like the committee to amend um
just a couple lines to clarify that if
the meeting has no physical
location that's when um Public Access
has to be able to be done remotely um
but under current law if the chair
declares that an emergency has occurred
there's still a requirement for a
physical location and uh and then a
quorum of the body has to be present at
that physical location um presumably the
public could then go to that uh physical
location um and so that's really the
distinction we want to make is you know
if there's a physical location for the
meeting that where the public should be
going um to get access by default
because there are uh problems as many of
you represent um rural communities and
communities without good connectivity as
well as small towns you know that uh the
conferencing software or you know
conference lines are expensive so it
puts a strain on your budgets to have
those for every uh board meeting and in
addition um you know if you have poor
connect ity um you might be able to get
one person on the line but you might not
be able to get uh get a bunch of people
on the line um depending on what your
internet speed is at town hall or
wherever the meeting is taking place so
we're just trying
to trying to change this a little to
make it uh more practical for for towns
to
implement and I'm happy to take
questions are there any questions
I guess I I have one question and that's
right at the beginning of the bill and
currently it says a public body may but
is not required to allow one or more
members of the body participate
electronically way it's Rewritten it's
one or more members of the public body
May participate in a meeting by
electronic so it seems to
shift the responsibility for determining
whether people can participate
electronically from the the from the
public body to the individual
members
yes it does seen that way and so
if if we have a
local
meeting uh and and I guess the question
is what is a public body
so is is a member of the public if I if
there's a planning board
meeting and you have a case before the
planning board are you a member of the
public body or is it just a planning
board member that has that op it would
just be the the board
membership um it would have to be the
the membership of the the body itself
not persons appearing before the board
although presumably even under current
law a board could allow some sort of
remote access for an applicant or or
other member of the public appearing
before it uh whether that's commentary
it thank you any other questions for Mr
Grace seeing none thank you for your
testimony
and the last person
who indicated in advance that they wish
pintto Pinto if you're out there raise
[Music]
attendees
uh so is there anyone else who wishes to
216 okay and there just a couple of
on hello Mr
Marshall
can you hear me now we can thank you um
first off um I want to thank you for uh
taking the time to listen to My
Testimony uh my name is James Marshall I
live in Derry New
Hampshire
um as a resident of um New Hampshire or
any area I think it's important to
participate in government um however
since I work in Boston it's uh very
difficult for me to arrange my schedule
to attend a meeting that may start on
time or like this one may not um or
other meetings that I've attended um
virtually have U Been uh suspended uh so
testimony is given you know postponed to
another week or whatever um so it's very
convenient for me to be at work like I
am right now and take an hour off um you
know to be able to attend the meetings
and participate I think it's important
that um not only for the state
government for for local governments to
make this um
ability um more prevalent to everyone
the bill specifically States telephones
uh which I think pretty much everybody
has um you know Zoom meetings are not um
necessarily required so I don't think
the technology questions being raised
are really that concerning since uh
there should be a telephone way to
communicate and if there isn't then the
person could certainly go to the meeting
themselves um basically that's all I
wanted to say is that um I I think it's
really important that we have public
access to these and um I appreciate your
time thank
you thank Mr Marshall any questions for
Mr
Marshall see none thank you for your
Perez good morning representative good
morning thank you Mr chair for giving me
the opportunity to speak
and um speaking on support of this
bill um I see a lot of more people
getting involved in our town and
Community meetings and I believe that
the uh having the the community involved
when it comes to making decision is
really important for every one of us and
then seeing uh people doing the
testimonies and given that perspective
or a lot of the issues in their
communities great for us
so I I believe this is a great
opportunity to continue giv uh people
who maybe the older or they have uh some
physical disabilities they can't get out
out of their houses but that they have
the ability to have a computer and they
have internet access and that they have
uh the access to these meetings uh is
great is a great tool to continue
keeping the community involved and then
um and make people feel like they are
part of the decisions in their
communities and thank you for the
opportunity to pick up thank you for
your testimony any questions for Miss
Perez again thank you for testifying
today and I think our last speaker is
Schmidt morning
representative good morning Mr chairman
uh can you hear me we can great I don't
know whether I could can join you by
video probably not but in any case I'm
here for the 6:30 uh Bill hearing at
that you've scheduled for 11 o'clock and
I just uh raised my hand to make sure
that uh I'm in the right format to be
able to reach you at that time okay oh
thank you are are you on schedule I'll
get I'll I'll pay attention
at yeah pay attention at 11 o'clock I
will thank you very much Mr chairman
committee members thank you I see no
other hands raised and so we'll close
the hearing on House Bill
216 and the committee will recess until
11 o'clock when we'll hear House Bill
everyone
resume
me
only
years
[Music]
spe
Mur somebody calling me Kurt are you
calling me is there an ex murderer out
there
no can you hear me Kurt I can hear you
good okay so I I I I was out of the room
for a second and I just thought I heard
a noise and I thought maybe someone from
the committee was is calling me okay
well I'm the only one here so okay well
good well it might have been you going
like e God the morning is creeping
by so I did let you know that I won't
make the executive committee meeting on
Friday yeah so it's good to see you you
got you got a fancy yellow tie on yeah
go change my Superman mask here
soon because I am wearing my bath
robe how we're going to do this I'm
supposed to be but I guess you guys I
can't I'm not on camera so you can't see
that excuse me representative welper yes
could you please let the chairman know
I'm gonna have to leave shortly I have a
dentist
appointment
okay so noted oh thank you you I didn't
realize you were on representative
Gordon okay I just didn't want to just
wonderful
11:00
on
what
for
e
morning again everyone we'll call this
meeting of the house Judiciary Committee
we are scheduled this morning to hear
House Bill 6:30 relative to remote board
meetings under the right to no law and
making the primary sponsor is
representative Maguire but I understand
uh that uh representative Schmidt may
be uh appearing on repes pres Maguire's
behalf
today and representative Smith are you
ready to
testify I am indeed Mr chairman I'm
breathlessly awaiting the dropping of
the gavel and your acknowledgement to
proceed as you will you may proceed
thank you very much and good morning
colleagues uh I've just uh finished a
Jael car meeting so I don't have to rush
back but I'm here uh to introduce uh
House Bill 630 uh to all of you this
morning um and if you've had a chance to
take a look at it you will recognize the
initial portion as uh very consistent
with the uh announcement that uh each
committee chair makes before we begin
our hearings these days uh in in this
new remote world we live in um it's just
very much slimmed down to the to the uh
you know most Central wording um and
purpose is not to uh to do anything
other than to
codify uh the governor's order so that
uh in circumstances that may require it
uh our committees and Boards can have
remote meetings as we are doing now but
at some point the emergency is going to
uh is going to end uh but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the covid
situation will be passed uh and so the
remote meetings serve a very useful
function as I think I think we all agree
um the latter portion of the bill uh
deals with um with signature
requirements that are currently uh you
know in in statute uh and the uh the
attorney for the office of professional
license insurance
certification uh Mr Tom bradrick uh is
uh intending to testify on the bill um
but uh the members of the the uh of the
sponsors uh on the on this bill are all
members of The Joint legislative
committee on administrative rules the
infamous jelar um and uh so uh we all
recognize uh that the that these uh
requirements uh need to be in statute uh
or amended to be in statute uh to enable
government to continue to function uh
under these current unusual
circumstances so that goes for does it
for an introduction if you have any
brief questions I'll attempt to answer
them at this time and then I believe Mr
bradrick uh will uh speak to you
afterwards I don't know whether anyone
bill any questions for representative
Schmidt seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chairman I think
we will call upon Tom Broad
is hello Mr bradick good morning can you
all hear me we can all right thank you
chairman G Gordon and members of the
committee so for the record I'm Tom
bradrick legal councel at the office of
professional LIC insurance certific
ification or oplc for background the
oplc provides administ and clerical
record keeping service and processing 54
commission while hb6 would affect all
the boards under opl's umbrella in what
we feel would be a beneficial way I want
to be clear that I'm only speaking today
on behalf of the oplc the AY I'm not
authorized to speak on behalf of the
boards so as as representative
stated um or I believe he stated this
bill was actually requested PLC we
worked with representative Maguire on
this um and the bill deals with two
general concepts the first is remote
meetings so very similar to the bill
prior to this that you just heard HB
216 piece is it deals with um just a
change to the
procedures I'll take both in turn so um
remote as you all know previous to the
pandemic RSA 91a required that a quorum
of any governmental body be physically
present in order to hold a meeting the
governor's emergency order number
temporarily temporarily waved this
requirement allowing agencies such as
op to meet remely so long as several
requirements are met lines 1 through 11
are meant to codify the governor's order
number so if this bill passes these
bodies would be allowed to continue to
meet remote the state of emergency
passed opcs wereing this change because
quite frankly the remote meetings have
worked out quite well from our
perspective for um the general public
which you heard about on the previous
bill um two our our board members and
three uh the oplc and broader the state
so first on the public we found that the
public have benefited from meetings
being held remotely because it's
increased public access to the
regulatory bodies of op um pre
previously if a doctor to listen in on a
discussion of medicine's monthly meeting
um they need to take time off drive to
conquer and physically attend the
meeting now they can just log in and out
of the remote meetings from their home
or or workplace they can listen to
portion of that meeting without having
to give up what can amount to hours to
physically in the board meeting second
the members of the boards under llc's
umbrella have also benefited uh remember
these are volunteer board members most
of our boards meet once per month rather
than driving in from say the North
Country into conquered for the meetings
the board members have been able to
Simply log on to remote meetings to
conduct the board's
business um and lastly there's been a
benefit to our agency and the state as a
whole um for our professional boards
most of our boards are comprised
primarily of people currently in or
retired from the profession with um
generally one or two public members on
the boards as well our board members
generally are nominated by the governor
and approved by the governor and Council
but it often comes to op PLC or the
board itself to try to find new members
when expire so historically has been a
struggle to find individuals who are
actively participating in their
profession uh half day full day every
month to participate on these boards
continuing to allow for remote meetings
would expand the pool of individuals
who' be willing to take on this
volunteer work um I I do as an example I
know of at least one mother who has kids
who has said she would not be able to
take the time to drive in to meetings um
but would consider being a board member
if if she was able to participate in
remotely um you heard extensively on the
readings piece previously so I'll now
turn to the second concept um the
remainder of the bill lines 12 through
21 are meant minor change to the
statutes concerning rulemaking that
appears in the administrative procedures
act RSA 541a in short for certain rule
making steps all rule making entity um
agency
heads but for us it's mainly board
members have to submit um statements or
cover letters that are signed by someone
making Authority right now uh a a wet
signature is required a photocopy or
scan is not accepted it's been
temporarily relax during the pandemic in
that the administrative rules office
will temporarily accept a photocopy or
scan of a signature but the expectation
unless it's changed is that the emergenc
is over we'll need to submit a wet
signature for everything that was filed
um via photocopy or scan during the
pandemic um here's where oplc is a
little unique for most agencies the
indivi individual granted rulle making
Authority is a state employee so for
instance if the person doing Ru making
for the Department of Agriculture needs
a signature they can usually go down the
hall to their commissioner and get that
signature but most of the rule making we
do OPC is Rule making for boards where
the board has the actual rul making
Authority most of our boards meet once
per month um some other smaller boards
meet quarterly it can be difficult to
get a wet signature from a board member
who in in non-pandemic times is in
office uh once per month for only
several hours so this change would allow
me I I do most of the ru making uh for
the agency to get the necessary
signature emailed or mailed to me and to
be able to file it in a timely manner um
photocopies of signatures are generally
accepted by courts if you look at New
Hampshire rule of evidence 103
photocopied signatures I believe are
accepted by governor and Council on
tracks for the state that come in front
of them I'm simply asking that
photocopies of signatures be accepted
for rule making purposes as well
um that concludes my oral testimony I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
Brad again thank you for your testimony
today thank you the next person to
testify is David sad from right to
know you just raise your hand so we can
go hey Mr sad you're on yeah okay thank
you my name is David sad I live in Ry
New Hampshire and I'm president of right
to know New Hampshire uh this bill is is
quite similar to the previous bill um
the testimony that I submitted in
written form is virtually identical so I
won't repeat myself I just want to um
add that again as it's currently written
we are opposed to it uh we certainly can
support it if it's amended uh based upon
uh the shortcomings that I uh mentioned
in in the testimony on the previous bill
um I would like to add a couple of
additional comments um if you are going
to amend the bill uh to allow the public
body members to attend
remotely then uh make sure that uh the
citizens are allowed to attend remotely
as well in other words uh don't
discriminate to give the public body
members greater or easier accessibility
to the meetings than you're affording
the public
themselves um it should be equal equal
access um and then I would just add um
many people we all see the benefits of
this
technology um but please look at some of
the amended language we're proposing to
make sure that you address some of the
technical problems that arise with this
technology
and to ensure that the public body
whether um inadvertently or on purpose
attempts to thwart The public's input
during an electronic uh meeting uh and
make sure it is a public record uh
available to the public in all instances
of for public meetings thank you very
much and I will take any questions any
questions for Mr
sad see none again thank you for your
testimony
Grace thank you Mr chair uh my testimony
will be abbreviated as well again I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association uh like the last bill we do
support this bill uh if we are given a a
preference on the wording for the
portion pertaining to the right to no
law um we would prefer the last bill
with the amendment that I proposed
that's all I I really have to say I'm
questions nice brief testimony any
questions
for Mr
Grace seeing none thank you for
testifying today thank
you next person who signed up to testify
Horan and if you could raise your hand
go missan you're you're on thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee
good morning I'm here in my capacity
today as executive director of the New
Hampshire Association of counties which
represents all 10 counties in the state
of New Hampshire both elected and
appointed officials I will be very brief
in my test testimony we support this
legislation we've seen increased
participation with both the public and
our board members and would like to
continue to provide that access to the
public in as we move forward and out of
this pandemic I'm happy to take any
comments but that is all I have at this
time thank
Horgan seeing none again thank you for
your testimony today are there any
630 seeing no one I'll declare the
hearing on the house bill 6:30
closed I will note that there were 10
people who signed up in support and 15
people who signed up in opposition to
the
bill and I I think I neglected to say
[Music]
on in that case there were 303 who
signed up in support and four who signed
opposition
and unless there is any other immediate
business will recess the committee until
our next year one
everybody
for
e
can hear
you yep we can hear you guitar here
should
hear actually that's much better Kurt
well yeah I'm sitting
about yeah closer to
the oh what a concept what a concept
putting the microphones right next to
who's speaking
like yeah you do sound much better
silver it looked like a Harry Potter
scene with you walking through your
bookcase a little bit
ago made me laugh you were real tiny and
you just walked right through
yeah come from way back there at the end
yeah well it being one
o'clock we'll call
uh call the house Judiciary Committee
back to
order next hearing which we're scheduled
to the next bill which we're scheduled
to hear this afternoon is House Bill
384 prohibiting the sharing of location
data primary speaker is representative
and the sponsor of the bill is
representative wer and would you like to
introduce the bill I would want the bill
Mr chairman so uh prohibiting the
data we we uh passed a constitutional
amendment uh having to do with privacy
and in since then we've been working on
defining what that
meant and this is just a small step in
the direction of this is one thing that
falls under that Constitutional
Amendment uh it it interestingly what
happened in Washington
the uh just a short time
ago the government called our phone
companies and they said we want to know
everybody who was in this area at this
time and they gave it the
information they there's no way they
could have gotten any kind of warrants
because they didn't know who they were
talking about that's what they wanted to
find out and then they went after they
could so they could find their
suspects they went through everybody's
cell phone data that's what this
business that's what this bill is really
all about we we deal with lots of
communications and many of them if not
all of
them use our cell phone data or capture
both we don't think that have sponsored
this bill that that data should be
shared for should be given to them or
they should have it for any other
purpose and the purpose for which we
gave it to them so I use an app when I
go walking and it tracks my location and
that's wonderful I wanted to do that
when I get lost in the woods I want to
get
home but I don't want them keeping it I
don't want them selling it and I don't
believe they should have the right to do
that and that's what this bill is about
so last year I had a house bill 1376 it
went through this committee very nicely
went through the house very nicely and
get caught in the
pandemic the bill that's in front of now
is a um what I want to call an amalgam
of my bill from last year and Senator
shander's Bill from last year which I'm
not sure exactly what happened in the
Senate but ended up on the
table and so I just like to say this is
what we're trying to do we're trying to
protect from location data
only from um
exploitation so that bill goes through a
long list of definitions Define
everything in the world and I'll tell
you the the the the list of definitions
is intended to be pretty much totally
encompassing so it talks about things
like uh a mobile application the mobile
application developer mobile
Communications devices
telecommunications
carriers the intent is to capture
everybody that's going to capture your
location data
and make it apply to them and of course
it defines what your data is your
geophysical
location and it says the bill
effectively says or I think
effectively that they can use that data
for the purpose for which you gave it to
them but they shouldn't be retaining it
and they shouldn't be giving it to
anybody else unless there's a a um
important reason so to protect some for
emergency
situations legal
process yes they can they can do that
you call 911 they can share your
location
down it's fine with me right or if it's
just for your own
much
um there isn't well I'll come back to
that so it provides an opportunity for
them it ca it creates create makes it a
crime for them to share your data
without your explicit
permission and they are subject anybody
$1,000 uh subject to a maximum of
person and it also creates a right of
civil
action which is unspecified being civil
action you can sue for whatever you want
if you can get it then you can prove to
cour you were damaged then you're
allowed to collect including your
reasonable attorney
fees uh I didn't I do have an amendment
to the
bill
because I was asked a couple questions
by co-sponsors and I didn't have good
answers
so Amendment uh
[Music]
replaces Roman numeral 2 paragraph a the
two it just
clarifies I'll just read it it says no
mobile application developer or
Telecom carrier shall share a customer
that's what that's Us location data
other than to fulfill an explicit
request from such customer unless the
customer has affirmatively waved such
right after being properly informed for
the purposes of this section continuing
to use a service or website shall not be
considered an affirmative W in other
words they can't blackmail you into
giving you your location data or for
them allowing them to use
it and that's what the meend that was
the same paragraph that was in the house
bill 1376 last year and I just thought
was a better paragraph than the one we
had so there it
is um and with that I'll just uh take
any
questions yes representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative welber for um
introducing this um and taking my
question um my question is specifically
around um like the gig economy like
specifically ride share apps um Airbnb
things like that um for instance if I
download if I download Uber onto my
phone and it asks me would you like to
share your data and that the question is
like always allow or allow while using
App um does this at all prevent like
this information from being shared to
the company for that no purpose no
that's an explicit permission from you
to them to collect the data what it does
it says they can't keep it and give it
to somebody
else okay so if I could follow up Mr
chair um in the Uber app it's says like
your ride history and it'll show like
where you traveled you know the night
before so to get home from a bar like my
trip from the bar to my house I can go
back into the app and look and see my
past trips and how much I spent in the
miles and all that other stuff um does
that prohibit existing apps from keeping
that data so that I could go then go
back and refer to that data um moving
forward so they're keeping what you
described they're keeping it for your
personal use so I see no reason why
they'd be prohibited by this from
keeping it for your personal use but if
I want to find out where he went last
night that's why we're trying to stop
Oregon you need to
unmute people probably wish I people
want me to have a mute button when we
get back to meeting in person I'm sure
but anyway president wer you brought up
uh for some reason the uh the uh what
the events of the US capital which I
actually would term as a terrorist
attack or at least anyway Le a pretty
upsetting thing and um and you seem to
be you seem to think it was a bad thing
that uh that these individuals were able
to be caught by using their cell phone
data um and so that is that what you
meant and but first I also want to point
out there there is a a line two sections
12 through 16 there does seem to be a uh
section that would allow you to use the
cell phone data if for some reason a bob
decid terrorist decided to invade our
cap our state house and or commit any
other similar crime and also uh also how
is how is this affected by the fact that
many of the individuals who've been
arrested actually willingly shared where
they are went out of their way to tell
the world what they were doing thought
it was a good idea at the time and for
whatever reason uh turned out not to be
such a good idea so
um how does the bill how does the bill
first of all I guess I mean you might or
might not want to say whether or not you
actually
support storming of the capital which
I'm pretty sure you didn't mean to say
but also like how does how does that
affect a situation A where serious crime
is being committed in the person is uh
especially when some of the people are
committing the serious crime are
actually like willingly sharing it on
social media and
elsewhere thanks so we'll take the
second part first the thing that you
share willingly in any public for like
social media is public information it's
you you've lost your right to privacy
when you put it on Facebook or Instagram
or Twitter or something like that right
you have sacrifi you've given it up
right so if they get it from monitoring
that type of thing
then that's perfectly fine that's just
public information it's not subject to
your privacy right
anymore so there's that on the other
hand if we have a demonstration in front
of the governor's
house and if somebody does something to
the governor's house I don't think that
law enforcement should be able to go to
uh AT&T of
Horizon and say or anybody and say I
want to know everybody that was within
500 feet of the governor's
house and get that
information I don't think they should be
able to do that if they have a
specific
reason New Hampshire Law requires right
now for law enforcement to get your
location data under the RSA
644 a warrant signed by a
judge
this is not as severe as
that but it's along the same line and
it's been suggested to me this should
have been put in RSA 644 for that reason
but I didn't draft it ol did that and we
can talk about that as we go forward in
the committee but I don't I just don't
believe
that if we have a right against
unreasonable searches it seems to me
that I want to know anybody that was
within a substantial area of any
particular ways is an unwarranted search
on those people
anything did you have a followup to that
represent how how General principle is
that I mean it's one thing one thing if
you're peacefully protesting but U you
know certainly what happened to Capital
turned something was far from peaceful
or even demonstration the governor's
house you know uh it's not view that's
uh something at least seems to be uh
perceived at least by the governor the
family is being uh crossing the line
from demonstrating to harassment and the
town even has an ordinance against it
which may or may not hold up in court so
like where's where's the line between a
situation where somebody's just
peacefully protesting and where they're
actually uh you know potentially or even
actually committing a crime so it's a
fascinating question to think about and
I would
um pretty much
agree that it's not an easy thing to
Define so let's just say there were only
10,000 people at that demonstration in
Washington only right and as far as I
know they've actually found something
like a hundred people who reached a
capital building that's a one out of
every 100 people at the demonstration I
don't think they should be able to get
10,000 people's location data to try and
find the 100 I just I don't think that's
right okay
Chase question I'm just curious and this
may not even apply but you know those
trackers that people can put on phones
for other people so that they're
tracking say their girlfriend or
boyfriend or kids and and as you may
remember from the floor you know there
there
are can you guys hear me or we listening
to somebody else can now we're having a
little interference okay
all right so the trackers that parents
put on or people put on to track other
people you have to buy those from
somewhere or they're an app is this
going to be under that um this
[Music]
ruling because it seems to me that a lot
of these people that are being tracked
don't even know that they are and that
would irritate me to no end so is this
something where it would be a
communication um business who sells the
tracker device to someone or the app to
follow another person without there
knowing so I don't think that the
provider the app developer or whoever
sold it as as you suggest can be held
responsible for the uses to which that
app is
put right okay so if it's the developer
themselves who are keeping all the data
from everything that comes through that
app then yes it would apply to them but
if somebody who bought the app and is
just being a bad person then no okay
thank
Simpson hi yes thank you for taking my
question representative welper um I've
been thinking about the public health
implications here I I know some colleges
have been using contact tracing apps uh
so they can avoid uh Corona virus
outbreaks and thankfully we haven't had
to resort to anything like that in New
Hampshire um in this pandemic but I I'm
wondering um how something like this
would affect if there were if we were
ever under dire circumstances and we
couldn't contain an outbreak for example
and we um needed to even temporarily put
some kind of contact tracing um get some
kind of contact tracing data from
people's phones I know some countries
have done that um I'm wondering if there
could be an exception in section four
not just for law enforcement purposes
but like extreme Public Health
emergencies or something like that what
what do you think about
that well it's an interesting question
and it's a difficult one so on the one
hand I kind of like to agree that maybe
there should be but take for example
what we're talking about right now with
the
virus if we're going to do that we're
going to have to say something along the
lines
of if the government wants to find out
everyone who's been in contact with this
person for a period of two weeks or
longer they can do
that I'm very nervous about that very
nervous so I would I would I don't think
we want to go that far at all right if
we're going to do anything like that
then I think it would have to be very
narrowly crafted to within a day or
maybe a couple
days I don't know I'm skeptical that's
why we already have RSA 644 it's because
we've already looked at this and said
look if the Law Enforcement wants to do
it they have to get a warrant so in the
public health area I can see there might
be some benefit to it but I'm very
concerned about a potential abuses being
much larger than in the law enforcement
area
my
comment represent representative Silber
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question really two questions one uh
in on page two lines two and three it
talks about uh the prohibition shall
share shall not share a customer
location data was collected while the
customer's Rob mobile communication
device was were physically present in
the town or city why is that language
important here it's
not and that's why removed well it will
be removed by the amendment that I uh
talked to first right for early on
Amendment 01558 says customers location
data on line it's line four of the
amendment but I think it's line two of
the of the bill other than to fulfill
explicit request from such customer
unless the customer is affirmative who W
the right it's extremely Broad and
targeted and says they cannot share the
data with absent an explicit request for
you or in a waiver that you have
explicitly been informed and let them
have it okay a quick followup Mr chair
certainly uh why is this limited to
mobile
devices why is this because if I go on
the web and I go to a site it it's for
my for my desktop and not a mobile
device frequently the site will say the
site wants to wants you to share your
location data yes no why is this limited
why is this limited just to mobile
devices not to all
devices well I guess the reason is
because we didn't consider the fixed
device as being
it doesn't move around so it's always
going to give the same
answer so but from a PRI from a privacy
perspective if if if they take my
location data from my fixed location and
they then aggregate that and they sell
it to these data mining companies or
something else it's got the same privacy
it maybe maybe
so I know that take right now now and
Trace anything that comes into one
computer to the geophysical location of
the or of of
origin right yeah they can do that
through why I don't know how they do it
but they can do it right so I can't stop
that I we just didn't think think of it
in terms of a fixed
asset okay thank you I I just I'm just I
was just a curious why there was limited
that's that's all because seems to me
that the same privacy concerns would be
valid as well for a fixed location well
if you want to work up an amendment with
me we'll talk about
it representative
Alexander um thank you and thank you um
representative welper for letting me ask
another question um I'm asking would
this also prohibit um selling location
data um when the like when it's
Anonymous so for in I guess my question
is like usually companies would use that
aggregate information to determine like
the needs of their um company or
industry in a certain city or how it's
used um would this also prohibit the
company from storing it anonymously for
those reasons for like their internal uh
use I don't think
so it's the best answer I can give you
there's there's a lot of things that
happen in the cyber world that I can't
speak to but no I don't think so it's if
they just say you know we have a 200
users in the town of straford and this
is what they do or this is what I I
can't see why that would be a problem
okay thank
you are there other questions I thought
I saw your hand up representative Smith
at one point in time do you have a
question no and I I did have one one
follow-up question this was this gets
back to the IDE idea of you
have 30 people outside the governor's
home somebody commits a criminal
act is it your intent that this bill
would prohibit the police from
determining who was at that location at
committed so the police right now have
to get a
warrant right
so that's what I meant with a warrant
well I said no
because law enforce law in here in the
exceptions of a law enforcement agency
in response to a lawful process in
section
4A they can they can give the
information to them but they have but
for answer law they have to have a
warrant
right okay you you can tell me if you
get a warrant for all the people whe
they're around this house at a certain
time I don't know that you could
could
okay and are there any other questions
for representative
wper seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you Mr chairman
thank you
committee there was actually no one else
who who uh pre-registered to speak today
but we do have some people who have
their hands up one of whom is
representative
yella representative yella would you
testify yes I
would you may proceed thank you Mr
chairman I wanted to uh speak to the
committee today about uh this bill HB
384 and I am currently in opposition to
to this legislation I believe
that um it as written even with the
amendment proposed is contrary to um the
protections
that that should be uh provided for
under under our law um I think that uh
it has major problems in so far as
chapter 64
4A uh talks about uh location
information and this bill talks about
location data and there is some
confusion as to what those two what is
the difference between those two things
also there is specific uh requirements
in
644a that require search warrants and
this uh bill
has um its
own language for what uh law enforcement
agencies um are allowed to get the
information from and it in nowhere in
this does it say uh required a warrant
whereas in 644a it does require a
warrant and so my concern is that there
is some conf usion and maybe uh either
we need to look at both of these
sections of RSA and combine them or
reference um because this bill seems to
be more focused at not government
agencies which would be uh the issue but
uh in uh
644a and in the Constitutional Amendment
it would be directed at government
agencies not private organizations and
what they do um this kind of also has a
potential to get
into uh whether or not people are able
to
contract uh if
they about sharing their data
and I think that so this this bill is
more focused on the private market and
not as much on the government
protections and in the
presentation uh from the sponsor it
seems also that the goal of this bill is
actually not achieved by the bill even
if it was to pass
um the the main reason why government
agencies are able to get um data from
the common carriers like phone calls and
telephone companies is um the via RSA
571a colon 1 which I have a bill to try
and
um uh limit their access to and uh make
sure that they uh get a warrant and so
my concern is more from the implications
of this bill and how it's written seem
to be opening up kind of a back door to
government
agencies uh if the
because because of the the language that
is used how it's defined and that
there's um multiple rsas dealing with
the same type of information so thank
you for uh letting me testify thank
you are there any questions for
representative
yella seeing none thank thank you for
your testimony
today the next person who has their hand
ber
there good afternoon members of the
committee are you able to hear me we are
excellent my name is Joseph Ebert it's
EB I'm a captain with the New Hampshire
State Police and I oversee our
Investigative Services Bureau which is
the detectives within the state police
uh so I I reviewed this bill on behalf
of the division and I didn't I don't
have any issue uh that I need to bring
forward with how it's written although
uh representative Gordon I thought your
question was exactly what my concern was
it seemed that uh the Bill's sponsor uh
his testimony unintentionally no doubt
seem to differ a little bit from what
the bill stated so my concern was uh it
seemed like he was not in favor of what
would commonly be referred to as a tower
dump uh which is when there is a crime
that's committed in uh close proximity
uh to a Cellular Tower and law
enforcement obtains a a court order or a
warrant uh to have access to those
individuals were within proximity of
that
Tower
um that that is a warrant process but
what what I was concerned with is it
seemed he seemed to be saying that he
disagreed with that uh because there
would be people who uh inevitably in
that situation have not committed a
crime but whose information would be
shared with law enforcement after uh we
had obtained a warrant and to that
extent if that is in fact uh his uh
feeling or the feeling of uh many people
I wanted to put forward to the committee
that that is a an incredibly important
uh tool that law enforcement uses uh it
is done with uh great scrutiny both from
the court system as well as from law
enforcement as to uh to not invade the
privacy of anybody who is not involved
in any type of elicit activity um but to
uh if there was the chance that this
bill would impact the ability to do that
uh as somebody who has worked kidnapping
cases and homicides I I can speak to
both of those as being uh it would it
would create uh an obstacle uh in being
able to successfully find the
perpetrator in in in those cases in some
instances so uh again as it's written I
have uh no problem because it says for a
lawful reason law enforcement can obtain
this information as it was testified to
I just wanted to clarify that um
hopefully uh the intent is not to
prohibit law enforcement from being able
to get a cell tower
uh and with that I thank the committee
very much for the time this morning and
I am certainly available or this
afternoon as the case may be certainly
available for any
questions is there anyone who has a
Eber yes representative
Paige Mr Ebert um you mentioned the um
scrutiny that is applied with respect to
um obtaining a warrant could you just
tell us if you're in a position to those
what the warrant requirement is what a
what has to be demonstrated before a
judge could issue a warrant sure so what
I can give you is uh a bit of a
hypothetical that's based off of many uh
instances in which I've been involved in
but uh for example um in a kidnapping
situation we will have a very long
affidavit um that lays out all of uh the
evidence that leads us to believe that
the crime was committed Within the
proximity of that Cellular Tower so
there will be a a laundry list of facts
and circumstances that say that on this
date at this time and is a very defined
period of time um and this date at this
time we are looking for every cellular
number that hit this Tower and we are we
are asking for that information because
we are trying to find the perpetrator
involved in uh taking a child from this
location which was uh in close proximity
to that Tower so it would not just be a
blanket tell it would be unworkable
first thing I should say to say give me
everything for a week because it's
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
numbers it's a time frame and there is
an affidavit that goes along with it
that says this is why we want this time
frame in this specific
area thank you for taking my question Mr
Eber
absolutely thank you are there other
questions singan thank you for your
testimony today
thank
Baker good afternoon can you hear me
okay we can perfect thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee uh my name
is Kyle Baker I'm with wrath young and
Pignatelli in coner and I'm here today
on behalf of the internet Coalition um
to respectfully oppose house building
384 um our members feel that this uh
bill um is incredibly broadly worded um
and could have some serious unintended
consequences um the internet Coalition
supports wellth thought out and narrowly
defined geolocation laws that adequately
solve a specific issue uh provide
remedies in an effective way and are
flexible enough to allow Innovation to
flourish while avoiding limiting an
entire segment of data um our member
companies adhere to strong privacy
policies which prohibit the sale of
location data by apps and these private
Pro privacy policies are enforceable
currently under the Federal Trade
Commission um some of the unintended
consequences um that we wanted to touch
on and we did submit a letter um
outlining these more thoroughly so I'll
be very brief and respectful of your
time um a big issue uh with this bill is
the creating a patchwork state-by-state
um approach to a sort of a national um
conversation and something that should
really be left more up towards the
federal government where we can have
uniform um because this bill as worded
um would not only cover New Hampshire
residents but anyone who's traveling
through or located in the state um so
this could mean um we would have to know
and more location data would have to be
shared just to find out where they where
somebody is in order to whether or not
they would have to be um subject to this
law um so anyone who is requ required or
wants to use data um as soon as they
were entered New Hampshire or if they're
passing through um would have to then
consent um to using this data again um
whether or not they're aware of this um
law being in place um
so geolocation information that's linked
to someone um specifically um should be
treated appropriately however excluding
animiz data sharing um from the
definition of authorized use um would
impact thousands of uh business models
out there um some of them have been
brought up already this afternoon
regarding whether it's ride sharing or
um any sort of GPS service that you
would use um that would require your
location um our customers are already
made aware of when their data is
required for these apps and people have
the ability to fully hand tailor The
Experience on when their data is used
and when it's not um so with that I'll
let the rest of our written testimony
and our letter submitted speak for
itself and uh thank you for your time
Baker do you have a question
representative Paige is your hand still
up or with that from
before I apologize Mr chair not a
problem any uh any other
questions saying none thanks for your
testimony today thank
you next person to testify is Andrew
Kingman
hi good afternoon folks are are you able
to hear
me we are fantastic uh good afternoon my
name is Andrew Kingman uh I'm general
counsel to the state privacy and
security Coalition we're a coalition of
29 companies and eight trade
associations across a wide variety of
sectors um and then I also am a a
privacy compliance attorney so I help uh
with da Piper uh privacy and cyber
security Practice Group so I actually
help counsil clients through uh various
data privacy laws uh throughout the
country um certainly you know similar to
Mr Baker's testimony we appreciate the
sponsor's good intention here in
drafting this bill but unfortunately it
is too broad and vague to be workable
here um you know effectively the the
sort of Topline summary here is this
bill would not be good for consumers and
it would not be good for businesses it
would dramatically increase consumer
frustration because it would require um
and particularly with the sponsors um
Amendment here would require a popup uh
notification every single time any
entity wanted to share any piece of your
um address uh or your physical location
where you were so uh if I ordered
something online and had to provide my
address I would need to provide optin
consent um again ride sharing if I
wanted uh groceries delivered if I
wanted a pizza delivered um it would
require companies to geofence the state
so that people coming in to go
snowmobiling for the weekend uh would
have to get a a delug of opt-in consents
just for crossing the state line um and
then this would happen every weekend and
and every time that we wanted to perform
any of those transactions the only
sharing that this bill permits um is me
sharing my location with a mobile app so
not with a telecommunications carrier
not with um a a retailer that I wanted
to have something somebody ship so it
doesn't really take into account any of
the payment processing any of the
backend operations that the online
ecosystem is built on um it also doesn't
apply equally uh there are immediate
dormant Commerce Clause issues because
it does not apply uh just to New
Hampshire residents this would you know
appear to try to apply to uh people
outside of the state as well and it
doesn't even apply equally to New
Hampshire residents because it only
regulates people and locations u in
towns so any unincorporated area would
not be governed uh by this um again you
know Mr Baker pointed out that because
of the way this bill is drafted
companies will be incentivized to
increase the amount of location
information collected so that they could
comply with this law and know where
people were so think of people who live
you in Windam and South who commute into
Boston every day would constantly be
getting uh opt-in consent notifications
every single day they leave and enter
um so anyways and and then the last
piece is that you know for small
businesses who often use free tools to
just uh know where their customers are
coming from right if I have a website
and I just want to know hey where are my
customers where are my visitors to my
website coming from um and using you
know free cookies um to just try to get
a broader sense of this uh that would
not be allowed and so it it's also going
to hurt small New Hampshire businesses
who are trying to increase their reach
um and again just use Simple free
everyday tools to uh to do that so um
you know we would respectfully oppose
the bill as well um and happy to answer
any questions thank you are there any
Kingman see none thank you for your
testimony
today thank you very
much and the next person to testify is
Chris
gilrain thought the next person to
testify
there we go I got excellent thank you
very much uh for the opportunity to
testify my name is Chris Gil rain I
represent
techet we submitted written testimony
alongside uh spsc so I will be brief um
New Hampshire as we all know very has a
reputation for being very business
friendly uh it's a reputation this body
has defended uh for for many many years
um and it's a reputation that gets
around particularly in uh as more
Investments have been made in uh
education and Workforce Development uh
higher Tech Industries are are starting
to look to Mass to New Hampshire uh I
know this specifically because before I
was doing this I was doing economic
development for the state of
Massachusetts and we lost a handful of
of high-tech opportunities to uh the
granite state so um you're you're doing
something well uh doing something right
here but uh business friendliness is not
just uh you know a good tax climate and
a strong Workforce it's also about
regulatory certainty um which is why
this
legislation technut is opposed to this
legislation terms as you've heard are
vague science will be very
difficult and the threat of potential
litigation
private right of action included in
this is could have a chilling effect on
Innovation entrepreneurship here
particularly existing services and
uh functions that New Hampshire
residents have come to rely on could
start to be phased out in the state well
as uh limiting the new functions and new
opportunities that could be rolled out
in the future uh with that that um I'll
gain if I could I I gather from your
testimony what you're saying is
that New Hampshire's business interests
outweigh the concern that's been
expressed with regard to people's
privacy oh I certainly uh hope I didn't
uh didn't indicate that no our members
are very take uh our consumer privacy
very very
seriously we have engaged on a number of
privacy issues in this state and on a
50-state
level we do as a general policy prefer
that these issues be handled at a
federal level just because it's so
difficult to regulate uh an industry
that crosses borders
constantly and uh you know we're happy
to work with the committee and and the
sponsor on more targeted specific
language to protect consumer privacy I
would not suggest that the business
concerns
outweigh about
privacy thank
Simpson hi thank you for taking my
question um related to the previous
question I I'm wondering if there are uh
laws that you have worked with other
states on that may be similar to this
that your um Association or your members
have been comfortable with that you
could send to us um so that we could see
kind of what the some of the things that
you ways that you might be open
to the balance that you were just
speaking
of uh thank you very much uh represent
restive Simpson yes we'll be happy to
follow
up any other
questions if not thank you for your
testimony
today thank you and I don't
see is there anybody else who wishes to
speak who hasn't had an opportunity to
do so yes I see there's a Jason Hennessy
speak thank you uh thank you Mr
and thank you honorable members of the
committee for hearing me out my name is
Jason Hennessy I'm a resident of Amherst
New Hampshire I have over 15 years in
the computer industry about and in
addition to about 10 years as a
researcher completing my PhD in
computational sciences and statistics at
South Dakota State and four years uh of
post-doctoral studies in Computing
topics at Boston University I've also
spent some time in in a research group
at a technology company since then uh
I've published I've published numerous
papers and wiely respected peer-reviewed
venues on related topics including
security privacy and system related
topics in Computing Technologies uh
including some that have received
International
attention so um I wanted to make clear
to the committee that the the the the
scope of this uh sharing so currently
your your location information is being
shared by your cell phone provider and
they don't just share it with with
companies they trust there's an entire
ecosystem of contractors that that sell
and resell and resell to the point where
pretty much anybody could buy if you
knew who to talk to you could pretty
much buy with a credit card and this is
not like archived information this is
like real time um so and this and and
there's articles that I'll be sending
you in my written testimony that
document that for at least about five or
eight years um we've known about this
practice and it was practiced by all of
the mobile providers so this isn't
something that uh the free market
unfortunately could solve because
because um all of the all of the
companies were doing
it um this practice was discovered and
then uh the cell phone companies
committed to ending it and years later
at least 2018 we discovered they had it
and so um and so there's a there's a big
concern that without legislation this
won't happen on its own um I personally
checked with one of these aggregators
they sold to location smart and was able
to pinpoint my own my own location
without having location turned on my
cell phone or anything else um it was
later discovered that a security flaw
with this uh with this contractor who
purchased everybody's location
information um meant that anybody in the
world with just a phone number could
locate could locate anybody's location
this includes stalkers burglar or other
people acting with nefarious intent um
in addition there were there were also
examples where a sheriff spied on a
judge illegally um and people spite on
love interests or former love interests
so this is a this is a real issue um
this I I really like this bill SB 384
because it uh goes beyond just the
Telecom providers and also addresses uh
two other major ways that that this
information's been shared IT addresses
um cars so many cars will share your
location information without your
knowledge um and also a lot of mobile
apps that are installed in your cell
phone so location information by itself
is extremely sensitive um it can say
where you know can it can show which
doctor's office you're going to uh it
can show where you're going to a place
of worship um you may not you may be
hiding from an abusive relationship or a
person and also when you've aggregated
all of this data on so many people a lot
more becomes visible who your Social
Circles are um who your friends are your
relationships other
things so
um yeah so I so so I enthusiastically
support HP 384 I wanted to address a
couple of comments that I heard
earlier um so rep representative Chase
brought up the tracking devices So
currently so in terms of tracking
devices you don't you know almost
everybody has a cell phone so um if you
know the company that's selling data you
could just bring a credit card and
purchase it you wouldn't even need the
you wouldn't even need the tracking
device and so this bill would actually
help to protect our privacy rights um in
that um responding to representative
Gordon and Captain Ebert's uh concern
about law law enforcement my
understanding is that the bill would
continue to allow law enforcement to
access data from anyone who has it as
long as the a lawful process were
followed uh responding to the internet
Coalition statement that there there
would be a patchwork of of States if
this would If This Were to be passed um
there's an AP article called influence
game Telecom lobbying muscle kill kills
privacy rules where it it discussed how
in in 2016 the Telecom Lobby exceeded
$123 million
um in spending the year before Congress
repealed privacy protections that would
have prevented internet providers
including Wireless telephone uh Telecom
providers from selling these uh privacy
sensitive data like location and
browsing history so in terms of whether
um in terms of whether like we should
wait for a federal a federal law you
know there's a lot of money being spent
to prevent that that these uh I suspect
that the companies that are lobbying
here have been spending so I I I think
that that argument is a little
disingenuous
um so keep in mind that the business
models that would primarily be affected
by this bill are those that sell your
information for profit primarily without
consent um and and in terms in terms of
like these privacy policies I just
wanted to I just took a look at two
Verizon Wireless's privacy policy is 22
pages and AT&T's is 27 pages so in terms
of actually actively getting consent um
I don't I don't think that uh I don't
think that the average person reads the
22 27
Pages um addressing the concern that was
uh brought up about authorizing uh
somebody's location used for Uber or
payments I don't think that I don't
think that that concern is is in line
with what the bill actually says the
bill says that U it defines authoriz
authorized use for when you're
fulfilling uh the the re request of the
consumer so Uber would be able to share
your location with anybody as long as
it's fulfilling your request and not
just it for any reason they feel like um
in terms of uh I heard a concern brought
up about somebody living in Windam who
commets Massachusetts would have to
click consent all day um there's nothing
in this bill that says that an
authorization expires when you cross a
border so that just seems silly to
me um and with that oh and then there
was one other concern uh that made very
little sense to me where they said pre-
tools that show where people are coming
from would need authorization so this
bill only applies to your cell phone
itself or apps running on it something
like a a cookie is based on your IP
address and that's collected at the
server that would have nothing
whatsoever uh to do with this so with
that I would um I appreciate the
committee's time and would be happy to
take any questions you there any
Hennessy seeing none thank you for you
representative Chase has a question I'm
so sorry thank you and thank you Mr
Hennessy could you just repeat again are
you here on behalf of just
yourself or um others no I'm just a
concerned citizen concerned citizen okay
thank you very much and thank you for
answering all the questions thank
you yeah are there any other questions
for Mr
Hennessy seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today and I see no one else has uh
indicated their
intent to
testify and so I will close the hearing
384 I'll note that there were 12 people
who signed up in support of the bill six
opposition and that gives us just a
couple of minutes before we end up
for
Mr chairman can you hear me I can and
Kim said she had the dentist
appointment yes okay I just she asked me
to tell you when it's 55 minutes after
iance
I got
that she had she had told me before she
okay so just in case anybody wants to
know Mr Hennessy was the
driver behind Senator Shandy's Bill and
behind my bill
I know him personally and he contacted
me about this and I told him he contact
his own legislators and Senator shamley
was the only one had interest two years
year
I had to relocate I was in the other
room and the sun was coming in the
window was making me look completely
white so I was wondering you've been in
many rooms today yes get a view of your
house it's
so well this is the this is the cottage
the
Rollinsford it's pretty and then with
all the um the Cardinals it's just
beautiful I was reading I didn't realize
that they turn bright red in the winter
that's why we see them so much more
time I've been watching the birds out
the window at the same time so have I I
have a bird feeder on my window it's for
think although they pounce at them I
don't do that Minister
TV
it's 2
o'clock and our next bill to be heard
this this afternoon is House Bill
474 prohibiting surveillance by the
state on public ways or
sidewalks the primary sponsor is
representative
Earth I don't know if representative
Earth is a yes representative Earth is
yes you you can you can proceed oh thank
you thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of the committee I'm
Representative Keith F Hillsboro
District 2 representing the towns of
Daring and wear sponsor of HB
474 I'm speaking in support of HB
474 I submitted written test to each of
you Wednesday that provides a summary of
the bill the history of the bill passing
the house last year and being laid on
the table in the Senate due to covid and
provides the relationship of the bill to
the Privacy amendment to New Hampshire
Constitution passed in 2018 with 81%
voting in
favor rather than repeating that I'll
simply relate the changes the bill makes
to the existing New Hampshire statute
RSA 236 col 130 titled Highway video
surveillance
this statute prohibits the state and its
subdivisions from using surveillance
technology to track the owner and
occupants of motor vehicles with some
exceptions as stated in the statute HB
474 adds the
following first in addition to
prohibiting the determination of the
owner and occupants of Motor Vehicles it
also prohibits tracking their
location second it prohibits determining
the Identity or track the location of
pedestrians on
sidewalks and third it clarifies the
relationship of the statute to our
constitutional right to privacy and
specifically references the statutes
that Define public ways and
sidewalks finally it provides a penalty
of $1,000 plus attorney fees for
violating the
statute these are the only changes to
the existing statute no changes are made
to the exceptions to the prohibitions
already in the statute
now after preparing the above statement
new information has come to our
attention earlier today that the
department of of natural and cultural
resources has a concern as it relates to
their current and ongoing activities and
I believe they sent a copy of the letter
to you all as well to bring them into
compliance with the current statute as
well as the statute as amended by HB
474 we recommend adding an amendment to
HB 474 adding a new subsection related
to exceptions to the prohibitions in the
statute this would be subsection Roman
numo
3-h reading as
follows is undertaken for security and
to facilitate law enforcement in the
investigation of criminal activity at
properties under the jurisdiction of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources provided that no video
recording shall be stored longer than 24
days except if needed in a Judicial or
administrative proceeding in a
particular case
the properties on which surveillance
occurs shall display signage indicating
the presence of 24-hour video
cameras I have contacted OLS with this
proposed amendment to be prepared for
the committee's consider
consideration I have not yet and I'm
looking now I have not yet um heard back
although they did respond that they
received it and they would look into it
a testifying at some point after me is
The Honorable Neil Kirk who authored the
original bill that has been resubmitted
this year in the interest of your time
it might be best to address your
questions to him as they relate to the
HB 474s you have in front of you um as
he can probably provide more in-depth
answers thank you for your time today if
you have any questions for me I will try
to address
them do any uh does anyone have any
questions
representative yes representative Silber
uh yes H how does this affect or does it
affect the cameras that are at the toll
booths where you go through and if you
have a transponder it may take your
picture and may not may take your
license plate or may not or if you have
neither it takes your picture and your
license plate and they end up sending
you a
bill well I can't tell how it affects it
in terms of a the way it currently
affects it but this this statute is
currently in law the the only changes I
made of the they're being made the ones
that I that I mentioned there so you can
already do all the things you said if if
you can already do all the things you
just said under current law then I
believe there's no change but I can't
speak to how the current law impacts
describing just a brief brief followup
Mr yes it sounds to me like reading
reading this proposed bill it sounds
prohibited and and in what way just says
they're they're using a camera other
Imaging device and to uh so that by
itself or in conjunction with other
devices can be used to determine the
ownership or location of a motor vehicle
the identity of a motor vehicle's
occupant Etc that's in the bill here and
that's what these cameras are doing in
order to send a bill to somebody who's
trying to evade the toll or who doesn't
have a transponder uh thank you
representative I guess I wasn't clear in
my a presentation what you just read is
current law that's not in the bill
that's not in the I mean obviously it's
still in the bill but it's not what's
it's already the law right now and if
you look at the entire statute which I
don't have right in front of me but
there's a subsection three in fact
subsection three is what I was
referencing in regard to making the fix
for the uh Department of Natural and
cultur resources giving you letter H
there's actually a through I already in
there which are exceptions to the
surveillance that you're reading which
which I presume permit what you're
talking about since as I say it's
already the law so if it weren't allowed
when I'm pretty sure it is then it' be a
problem already if you follow what I'm
saying thank you
yes representative
Chase thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh Keith for taking my question I'm just
curious with these
cameras or the viewing of the say the Ry
Police Department Hampton police fors
management the the letter that we
received are is this something that
somebody sitting in an office watching
and maintaining or is it on a loop and
how often is
it um I'm not familiar with the letter
you're referring to but I do know that
uh representative or former
representative Kirk has spoken with
several police departments regarding I
think the issues you're raising so it's
probably best to address that question
to him and he could probably give you a
much better answer than I can give
you okay thank
representative see none thank you for
your testimony today thank you
sir and perhaps it would be best to call
upon former representative The Honorable
Neil
Kirk
available
Mr chairman can you hear me now we can
hear you now good afternoon to you and
to members of the committee for the
record I'm Neil Kirk and I live in wear
um current
statute uh on the
books was um interpreted by a court to
mean something other than I believe what
the uh legislature intends Ed and the
that the law that is being corrected is
RSA 236
170 and that's currently on the
books um I received a copy of uh a
letter from the Department of Natural
and cultural resources saying that the
law the amendment would impede their
current
activities um and as I read the law now
what they are currently doing is
prohibited under current
law so I believe um in order to fix the
problems that they've raised with use of
cameras on trails and parking lots and
Gates uh where Vehicles access to State
facilities requires an amendment to
current
law and um I believe representative F
has indicated that he has such an
amendment and that that will solve that
problem if that amendment is not passed
then then the uh department is violating
current law and of course would be
violating any
Amendment the purpose of the amendment
as I say is to correct a
misinterpretation of this statute by the
courts or at least what I think was a
misinterpretation and the purpose was
basically
to um
bar the use of cameras on public rights
of way meaning intended to mean State
highways and and and uh so that uh the
state didn't set up surveillance cameras
the way they have them in Britain or New
York City and track people throughout
their uh the course of their daily or
monthly or yearly or lifetime activities
keep a record of this and then use it
for whatever purposes they want um the
recently adopted ed u informational
privacy amendment to our constitution I
think would prohibit that and this law
is an effort on the part of the
legislature to deal with that as a
matter of public policy so the
correction that the bill makes um which
I believe the court
misinterpreted was to make it was to
make it clear that the existence of a
camera taking those pictures is
something that on the roads is something
that the legislature didn't want if you
or I are going to visit uh a medical
doctor or going to a political rally and
we take our car to do that it seems
quite inappropriate that the state would
be taking pictures of us and creating
records of where we went and what we
were doing so the first section of the
bill prevents the or makes it clear that
taking those kinds of pictures is is not
allowed the second part of the bill
expands the definition of roads to
include
sidewalks um because the the first bill
apparently didn't do that the statute
doesn't do that and
finally um a right of civil action is
granted to a person whose rights have
been violated by the state's use of this
use of these cameras i' point out to you
that this bill only applies to the state
counties municipalities it does not
apply to the private sector it strictly
deals uh with with state government and
state uh created
entities
that completes my testimony Mr chairman
I'd be pleased to answer any questions I
understood there was some sort of a
letter from or comment from police
departments I have not seen that um I
was in touch with um Chief David Cahill
of
snipe asking whether or not he had or
the police had any issues with this I
have not heard back from him so if
testimony has sub been submitted by the
police Chiefs I'm not aware of it I'd be
pleased to answer any questions Mr
chairman thank you representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and
thank you honorable um Kirk for
answering my question um my question um
specifically is around like parking
meters so when when somebody gets a
ticket you know in downtown Manchester
for a parking violation um the maid will
typically take a picture of where the
car was um at that moment um just to use
as evidence in case there was it like a
hearing or anything so under this bill
that would be prohibited and I guess my
followup to that would
would there be any way for the state to
prove that the car was parked in a
certain spot if an appeal was done if
this if this is not a
lot
um I'm not sure what kinds of pictures
are being taken let's assume it's with a
cell phone that kind of picture is that
what you're talking about representative
Alexander um I'm I'm talking
specifically about they have like pads
that they'll do that they'll take a
picture of where the car was like on the
sidewalk at a certain like with a time
stamp on it um that's happens on a
regular basis in downtown Manchester so
I guess that's my question well please
note that the bill doesn't prevent
taking pictures it prevents using a
camera take to take pictures to identify
a vehicle or to identify its
occupants now I don't know exactly what
it is that the
um what kind of a picture the the uh
meter made is taking but if it's not to
identify the vehicle or the or or its
occupants then it's not prohibited by
this bill by this current statute or by
this
bill representative Chase thank you Mr
chair and I just wanted to put my hand
down what I was referring to before when
I said about the Ry Police Department
Hampton and the force it's the the
letter that or testimony we got had
today from the state of Hampshire
Department Department of Natural and
cultural resources the same one you had
mentioned so there was nothing that was
received from any
individual Department as far as I know I
just wanted to clarify that so you
weren't wondering about it thank you
very much that puts my mind at ease but
I one thing I'm not sure if you are the
one that the last person told me to
refer to do you know how that's being
worked is there is this something that's
at the dispatchers office and they're
watching the cameras or is it on a
looped reel that after a certain amount
of time the tapes are erased you know
like like a surveillance camera
and um you re
reloaded you you may thank you for that
question representative Shas you may
have reached the limit of my knowledge
about these kinds of activities but let
me just say that there are two
circumstances which may help you there
is an exemption for parking lots in the
the park and ride system in the current
statue and in those situations they
mount cameras on poles and the cameras
are taking pictures and those cameras as
I understand it are not being
supervised they're used to um deal with
perhaps theft or break-ins um and if
there's a break-in then they look to the
cameras film and use that to prosecute
um there are also cameras I Believe on
Route 93 that are mounted on poles that
take pictures of vehicles going back and
forth and those are viewed by a central
loc at a central location I believe in
the Department of Transportation
facility I think it's in lonia and those
are not recorded they are live only and
they are used by the department in cases
of accidents so that if a truck tips
over and there are hazardous materials
or something like that uh identific
ation can be made and information passed
on to the police departments those are
the only areas that I'm aware of except
perhaps some communities are illegally
using cameras for other purposes but
those are the only two situations that
I'm aware of where cameras are being uh
used
appropriately thank you very much that
helps are there other questions for
former representative
Kirk I guess I'd just like to follow up
on
uh representative sobber's question to
representative Earth and with regard to
the PO boo specifically the Easy Pass
where they're taking pictures of
vehicles going through and he thought
that there might be an exception for
that is there an exception in the law
for that as well um I believe there is
an exception I don't believe it's in
this bill I believe it's in the Easy
Pass
bill um but but I I found it I found it
in the statute in the existing statute
thank
you and the the the other thing and I
think this is the same question that
came up last year in this or a similar
Bill and that's with regard to the use
of the word I think surveillance more
than anything else because surveillance
just and this is sort of a followup to
what representative Chase was talking
about is surveillance tends to think of
a a continuous behav Behavior as opposed
to a single event like just taking a
picture a one-time picture but as I
understand it as it's defined here it
would mean the use of surveillance would
include just a one time taking a picture
is that
correct
um I don't believe that was the intent
but I think the language could certainly
be interpreted that way
um it the the as I said before uh
representative Gordon the purpose of the
bill was to prevent a record being kept
of where people were and what they were
doing and hence
surveillance was intended to mean
exactly what you described the ongoing
continuous activity as opposed to a
single
picture um I thought there was something
in the statute that dealt with it but
read that that gets to the it seems to
me it gets to the issue that was raised
by representative Alexander that you
know a one-time event of taking a
picture for a
vehicle because
it's I think I found it Senator uh
excuse me representative um if you look
under uh RSA 236 130 Roman
3B it says the prohibition set forth in
paragraph 2 that's the surveillance
prohibition shall not apply where
surveillance and this is uh B is
undertaken on a caseby casee basis in
the investigation of a particular
violation misdemeanor or
felony so this I think would clearly
exempt the meter made taking a picture
of the car or or a policeman using a
dash cam or anything like that to take
pictures of a particular
incident and I believe that was put in
there just to deal with that situation
so I think representative Alexander's
concerns are specifically addressed in
the current statute and that of course
would continue in effect it should house
bill um 474 be
enacted in other words no the the house
bill 474 does not make any change in the
rest of this uh bill which has uh as
representative Earth said um eight or 10
uh exemptions from the general
prohibition thank you representative
Horgan um thank you very much Mr chair
thank you much uh former representative
Kirk good to see you again even if we
can't actually see you but um my
question is how does this affect uh
public institutions like the uh like
like the State House itself which has
they have video surveillance cameras
most of which don't show images of
public ways but I know there's at least
two camera angles there's a one that
actually I he CH it founded on the L
that looks the front lawn of the L and
obviously takes in a block of North
State Street and then there's also a one
that overlooks the lb parking lot which
also shows part of Green Street so was
your tent is
that uh public insent can still deploy
cameras in places like that or is your
intent to say that they should shut that
we should example shut those two cameras
down because they would be violation of
of this law if I didn't know you better
representative Oregan I would think that
was a
softball um it's good to see you uh
section again the prohibition shall not
apply to I'm reading on Roman
32d
um is incidental to the monitoring of a
building or other structure under the
control of the state or a political
subdivision of the state so if the
conquered Public Library were to put a
camera over its front door as you said
the State House were to put a camera on
the building and it caught pictures of
people driving by on the various streets
that would not be a violation of the
statute that's specifically
Exempted
thanks and that's again that's not in
the amendment that's not in the bill
that's in current law okay good thanks
any other
questions
if
not first of all it's nice to hear from
you again and thank you very much for
your testimony I appreciate it Mr
chairman it's good to see you in your
role your new role one of
many thank you uh the next person would
rusa good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the committee and thank you for the
opportunity to testify this afternoon my
name is Jeannie haruska I'm the
political director for the American
civil liberties Union of New Hampshire
and I'm really here actually in support
of Representative Kirk uh we strongly
supported the the original bill that he
passed in 2006 and really do see this as
an opportunity to restore what he and we
believe the legislature intended with
that original bill um which was to guard
against generalized surveillance and to
make sure that New Hampshire does not
become a surveillance State um just by
way of example New York city has an
estimated 18,000 cameras linked to a
system the New York uh police department
calls quote domain awareness system some
estimates indicate that London has
upwards of 600,000 surveillance cameras
um and if you want a for another example
on that by next year China is projected
to have one public camera for every two
people um so there are a number of
examples where cameras are just becoming
ubiquitous and New Hampshire for a long
time has been a state committed to
privacy um and rather than waiting for
cameras to be erected and trying to take
them down this is an effort to try and
prevent that sort of surveillance State
um ahead of time um so representative
Kirk uh I actually want to quote him
because we pulled up some of the
testimony from the 2006
uh legislation and he when he uh fought
successfully for that 2006 legislation
he said at the time quote this is a bill
that basically says that the state shall
not take General surveillance pictures
of the citizens traveling on the state
highways all this bill does is that it
says that there can be no generalized
surveillance um and so I want to stress
that and flag um representative Kirk
mentioned a couple there are a number of
exceptions to this in current statute so
I really encourage the commit to take a
look at RSA 236 colon 130 because a lot
of the questions that have come up um
are addressed by those very specific
exceptions there's um as has been noted
there's an except there's a specific one
for toll collection um there's a
specific one pertaining to caseby casee
investigations um and I think what the
what those exceptions point to is that
the bill is is geared towards General
surveillance right cameras that are not
focused on a specific incident but are
permanently um built into the
infrastructure so that there's no
there's no way to walk down the sidewalk
and not be captured by the camera right
the camera is not investigating a crime
it's just there um and so you can
imagine right you're going to your
therapist's office you're going to the
doctor's office um these are times when
you really don't want to be caught on
camera um and so the goal is to try and
prevent the state from just erecting
cameras around town where when used
together could really track your
movements and reveal a lot about you and
your private life um including your
doctor your relationships your social
life um so that's really the intent of
the bill and again we think all this
statute does is go back to what the
legislature intended 14 years ago um so
this isn't new ground it's just
reaffirming what the legislature
intended to do when it when it passed
the RSA back in 2006 um so we strongly
support this bill we supported it last
year and we encourage the committee to
vote a to pass I'm happy to answer any
hesa seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
Abbott thank you uh chairman Gordon uh
committee members for the record my
name's Gary Abbott uh I'm the Executive
Vice President of the associated general
contractors of New
Hampshire um I'm gonna I'm probably
gonna throw a curveball a little bit
because I do think the chairman brought
up the word
surveillance uh I brought this bill
before contractors who work on do and
administrative Services projects and the
construction industry uses a lot of
cameras today more cameras today than
they did in
2006 and one of the concerns was we are
we an extension of the state when we're
working on a state
project so if we're working on an i93
project I I'll give you some cases we
take lots of pictures with phones uh for
grades all of the GPS type systems out
there contractors use drones and we get
a lot of the public ways so we're using
cameras and there were I can tell you
when I brought this up my committee
raised a lot of uses of cameras that are
currently being used on a construction
site so we question the word
surveillance uh I think we're kind of
like some of the other people that are
commenting to you uh we're reading this
whether those kind of project specifics
where we might get a vehicle we might
get a person on a sidewalk um whether
this applies to us so I don't have the
legal question of whether we're an
extension or a political subdivision of
the government when working on their
projects I also recognized when it went
in uh I watched this bill back when it
was first proposed represent Kirk
regarding toll boost and I believe the
addition in this bill it was raised
earlier you add the word or
location uh unless you put some kind of
exemption under the toll boost statute
that this doesn't apply that this it
would conflict because toll boosts are
clearly taking the picture of the
license plate and the location the time
and all of those things and it is new in
this new language and it could be in
Conflict but let's go back to um it's
great to have a he hearing where I can
pull up on a computer uh RSA 236 colon
130 I could not find construction as
exempt on that
list I looked at all the different
options and I don't see where it's clear
uh whether we be in compliance or not in
compliance with the proposed statute and
clearly we're in the public RightWay
within the ways of the the the
definition of this so I guess I'm going
to leave it up to the wisdom of the
committee whether there's an exemption
that should be put in because I I
definitely heard uh former
representative Neil Kirk say it really
doesn't involve the
individuals but in the case where we
might be considered an extension of the
state it's not really clear it's getting
a little gray so my group wanted me to
bring forward to you these concerns and
it really is a question of whether we
should be added to the exemption
under 236 130 uh that section where it
has clear exemptions for the state and
their cameras whether construction for
the incidental use of uh doing a project
would be considered uh exempt from this
regulation so what I'd end my testimony
with those two issues that are before us
as we're trying to interpret this new
language thank you for your testimony
seeing none again thank you for
testifying today thank
you the last person who who signed up
pre-registered to sign to speak today is
Ross
Conley hi Mr chairman can you can you
hear me we can oh thank you so much for
for having this hearing today uh just
for the record my name is Ross Connelly
the deputy state director for Americans
for Prosperity in New Hampshire and I'm
here to voice our support for HB
474 uh as we've heard this bill protects
state agencies or prohibits I'm sorry
prohibits state agencies from engaging
in warrantless surveillance of the
citizens of New Hampshire HB 474 updates
existing law on Highway video
surveillance and prevents cameras and
other devices from being used to
determine the ownership or location of a
motor vehicle and as the Supreme Court
has recognized we all have a lower
expectation of privacy when we drive on
public roads but the court has only
created a constitutional floor for
privacy and this legislature can and
should do more to protect privacy and
given the rapid deployment of tracking
technology this prohibition is
absolutely
necessary uh the people of New Hampshire
spoke very loudly two years ago when 81%
of Voters passed the Constitutional
amendment to protect their privacy and
this bill goes a long way to protect the
right to as the amendment States live
free from government intrusion uh in
private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent uh and
just want to be brief uh and for those
reasons we urge uh the committee to to
move HB 474 ought to pass and I'd be
happy to take any question
uh that the
committee any questions from Mr
Conley see none thank thank you for your
testimony today thanks so much for your
time is there anyone else who wishes to
testify today who hasn't signed up to
testify
hearing I note this for the record that
there were 15 people who signed up on
our website to support the bill and four
2:30 all to order our hearing on house
concurrent resolution three declaring
that the Claremont cases mandates
that the legislature and executive
branches Define an adequate education
determine its cost fund its entire cost
with state taxes and ensure its delivery
through accountability are not binding
on the legislate legislative and
executive branches the primary sponsor
of this bill is representative gwikii
and will call call upon representative
Wiki to introduce his legisl proposed
legislation
uh good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm here today
to introduce this resolution it was
first introduced around a decade ago by
representative Michael balbon the
speaker at the time caused it to be
killed in Committee in order to
substitute a poorly written
Constitutional Amendment the result was
that neither the resolution nor the
amendment went anywhere some members of
this committee are lawyers and have more
trust for the courts than those of us
who come from different backgrounds I
ask all of you to listen with an open
mind and the clear language of the
people's Constitution that is the
supreme law we've been given and have
sworn an oath to as legislators we have
no Duty or Alle courts read article
seven of our constitution the relevant
parts of article 83 are in the testimon
testimony I email to the committee a
while ago okay article seven State
sovereignty the people of this state
have the sole and exclusive right of
governing themselves as a free Sovereign
and independent state and do and Forever
After shall exercise and enjoy every
Power uh jurisdiction and right
pertaining there to which is not or may
not here after to be by them expressly
delegated to the United States of
America and Congress assembled article
83 is on the encouragement of literature
Etc and uh joins us to cherish uh the
interest of uh Lit Literature The
Sciences Etc the plain language of
article 7 is clear and prescriptive
there's no room for interpretation words
have exclusive right and shall are
unambiguous and prescriptive the plain
language of article 83 is clearly
aspirational not prescriptive words
encouragement and cherish are not
prescriptive if it were prescriptive
then would we not be obligated as a
legislature to provide financing for the
other things article 83 encourages and
cherishes the article say cited above
are plain English of our constitution
words that aren't found in our
Constitution are President uh precedent
steroid diseases and co-equal these are
legal constructs they may be useful to
the courts but they are clearly inferior
to the people's Constitution tion into
the statutes enacted by The People's
representatives from Wikipedia one of
the most important rules of Precedence
or roles of precedents is to resolve
ambiguities in other legal texts such as
constitutions statutes and regulations
the process involves first and foremost
consultation of the plain language of
the text as enlightened by legislative
history of enactment subsequent
precedent and experience with very
text um capricious use of precedent the
courts have addicts full of conflicting
precedents in Claremont the court chose
to base their decision on a Kentucky
president while a ignoring article 7 of
the New Hampshire Constitution they used
article 83 of our constitution as a
false justification of their decision in
doing so they turned the plain
aspirational language of article 83 on
its head it said that precedents make
the law predictable and knowable to lay
people however the converse is often
true if the courts are free to pick and
choose among precedents and ignore
pieces of the Constitution and statut
that don't suit their whim then they use
of precedents to justify their position
is essentially an overturning of the
Constitution and elected government when
our constitutions were first enacted in
1784 and
1789 they were the philosophy of freedom
and self-government put into words quote
Thomas Payne one of the philosophers
precedent law is one of the viol systems
that can be set up here we are 237 years
later and our constitution has been
supplanted by precedent law the people's
Representatives have become infer to
unelected judges I ask the vote
committee to vote off to pass on this
HCR and take one step toward restoring
self-government and the people's
Constitution thank you Mr chairman and
committee members if there are any
questions I'll be happy to take them
thank you very much representative
Horgan oh thank you very much Mr chair
thank you much represent Wiki um I'm
just trying to figure out here is U
obviously you objected to Claremont
decision but is that strictly because of
the policy where like that we frankly
have never gotten around to passing laws
that eat the requirement to clont
decision or is it uh or do
also object to the result of it which is
where which is whereby towns that have
uh lower tax bases still uh have a
better chance of educating their
children so is it the it merely the
result of the Claremont decision that
we're trying to overturn here or is it
also like the uh it merely the process
but that followed that decision today is
specifically for
however the basic principle that the
constitution belongs to the people not
to the courts is the basis for this know
the fact that we've had to uh reinforce
our Bell of Rights numerous times um
article 2A article 8 uh concerning
standing um the one that was mentioned
before concerning privacy these things
were all in the Constitution already and
this is just really an attempt on the
specific subject of school funding to
say that that is the perview of the
legislature are not of the courts very
clearly money bills must um or originate
in the house they don't originate in the
courts and this is clearly the opposite
of that and so we need to overturn it
and doing it just simply by a
declaration of the house
saying essentially pound sand for this
session is what this uh resolution says
that's thank you for follow up Mr chair
may I guess that sounds like it's a
process you didn't like but U and the
represent Bon's I sitting here so I've
got the website you can look up what
ex-members are introduced with this be
the HCR 26 which he introduced um yeah
exactly 10 years ago in the 2011 session
which was retained by uh was rained by a
special committee on education funding
reform and then came to the floor in
January and basically was uh referred to
interim studies was that the HCR you're
referring to exactly that it's those are
the exact words which leg Services gave
to me okay great
thanks any other questions for
representative
lki seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you Mr
chairman uh
the the next person to speak is uh
another former representative Doug
Douglas
Hall
may have there go I am sorry I got it
unmuted now um thank you Mr chairman I'm
Doug Hall I'm a retiree a resident of
Chichester for 49 years and a member of
the board of the after school funding
fairness project 30 years ago I was
chair of division two of house finance
committee and responsible for school
funding at the time of the augen Blick
formula and before the Claremont
decisions after those decisions as
executive director of the New Hampshire
Center for Public Policy studies I
researched the history of school funding
in collaboration with the New Hampshire
Historical
Society the paper what did they mean by
Cherish that I submitted to this
committee uh yesterday is a short
version of that history I hope all
committee members have received
that hcr3 is based on an erroneous
understanding of History its text
includes statements that are not factual
while they're numerous misstatements I'm
going to discuss only four and I'm going
to provide you the page and line items
page two lines five to six of
hcr3 this statement implies that the
court has defined educational adequacy
determine the cost of an of Ed
educational adequacy specify how to fund
it and to provide accountability this is
also stated on page one of hcr3 line 7
and8 I would challenge the sponsor to
site those places where the court has
done so nothing could be further from
the truth the court in its numerous
opinions on this issue has stated
clearly that those responsibilities are
the domain of the legislature the court
has stated that whatever decisions the
legislature makes however
must comply with the two constitutional
responsibilities to provide education
and that tax rates must not vary among
taxpayers some of what follows in hcr3
is noted already is copied from text of
HCR 26 and that in turn was copied from
a legislation in the
2001 uh legislative
session page two lines 16 and 18 through
18 if you've read the paper I submitted
you will recognize that this is a
complete misunderstanding of the first
50 years cited during those years it was
this legislature that set the amount to
be raised and spent on schools in every
town in the state there were no school
boards Selectmen who may or may not have
funded schools under the old provincial
laws were told on no uncertain terms by
this legislature that they were required
required to raise by taxes the amount
the legislature deemed necessary under
the new constitution this was a complete
takeover of school funding by the state
from what had been a relatively L Fair
system under earlier law to make their
point even further the new law stated
that any Selectmen who did not comply
would have the necessary funds for the
schools in their towns taken from their
personal
Estates later the legislature even
doubled the amount to be taken for
non-compliance page three lines 13 to 16
of
hcr3 here it cites that important first
law and states that that
law quote constitutionality was never
cast in doubt unquote so true but the
sponsor of hcr3 never describes what
that law did as I've described it took
control over the funding of schools from
local Boards of Selectmen and gave it to
this
legislature our Supreme Court did not
ignore the action of the first
legislator as stated in these lines it
reminded current legislatures of what
those early legislator understood to be
State responsibility and had done to up
hold that
responsibility it was only in the 1890
to 1919 period that local school boards
began to supplement the amount required
by the legislature the way schools are
now funded were funded in our generation
and in our parents generation is most
certainly not how they were funded
before
1900 page three lines 21 and
22 if this legislature quote findes and
declares that the amount of State
funding for public education required by
the Constitution has been and remains
zero dollar on quote it would come as a
complete surprise to John Sullivan John
Pickering and others who wrote that
Constitution and enacted its first
school
law thank you for the time to set the
historical record straight if anyone on
the committee would like a copy of my
longer paper on this subject please send
me an email and I'll I'll send you a
copy are there any questions for for
your and the is Jeff mcclinch available
to
testify
and Jen are you
there see Jen there yes I am okay can
you I don't know if representative Smith
is active so could you get put Jeff make
me a co-host
or put on Jeff MC linch he's here can
members of the committee hear me we can
wonderful well good afternoon uh
chairman Gordon and members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify this afternoon on house
concurrent resolution three for the
record my name is Jeff mcclinch and I'm
the Project Director of the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project uh the fair funding project
opposes hcr3 and respectfully request
that the committee recommend the measure
as inexpedient to legislate it does so
for two reasons first as Mr H has
already explained the measure is based
on a misreading of legal history and the
history of the state of New Hampshire's
role in ensuring that every child
receives an
education second offers no constructive
response to the very real short and
long-term challenges now before New
Hampshire's public schools and instead
seeks to absolve the state of its well
established responsibility for
supporting them and I on
second in the coming year cities and
towns are expected to lose close to $90
million in State education Aid due both
to the covid-19 pandemic and changes in
law that decline would likely Force
municipalities to turn to significant
property tax increases or to severe
spending cuts as they set their school
budgets for the next academic year hcr3
would neither prevent such declines nor
ease the potentially damaging decisions
local officials now face nor ensure that
the children of our state receive a
quality education rather it offers a
rhetorical declaration that the checks
and balances so vital to our democracy
are simply null and void
other measures now before the
legislature such as Senate Bill 135
which the Senate approved yesterday
would address those chall in a far more
subsi Manner and I urge the members of
the committee to support them
instead sadly these short-term
challenges are in some ways extension of
of those much longer of excuse me
extension of the much longer term
problems plaguing New Hampshire's school
funding system our report prepared for
the recent commission to study school
funding summarizes those problems
clearly and succinctly noting and I'll
just quote briefly the current system is
inqu inequitable from both student and
taxpayer perspectives District serving
the highest proportion of students who
are economically disadvantaged spend
District moreover the districts with the
least property wealth per student impose
the highest local education tax rates to
be able to fund their children's
education other legislation now under
consideration in both Chambers Senate
Bill 155 in the case of the Senate and
and House Bill 608 in the case of the
house would take important steps towards
mitigating these inequities and
empowering local districts to provide
every child with the kind of education
they will need to thrive hcr3 represents
not a concrete plan for future action
but a rhetorical revisitation of past
debates accordingly I want more urge the
committee to recommend hr3 as
inexpedient to legislate and I'd be
happy to try to answer any questions
members of the committee may have are
mcclinch seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you we do have another person who has
Maguire uh thank you very much Mr
chairman may I uh testify with
video
uh I think you we have a your picture up
right now Mr chair I can promote him to
in
there
we here we go thank you very much Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record my name is Dan Maguire
I'm from Epsom and I'm here to support
representative lii and and
hcr3 and I don't want to argue with the
representative Hall's scholarship which
certainly I have not read his paper but
it sounds complete and the question here
is not whether the the um legislature in
the past uh supported schools and if so
how it's the question is can they be
ordered by the court to do so in a in a
specific way and in more detail does our
constitution in uh part two article 83
require them to support schools in a
particular way to a particular amount
and so on and um if you read the
original clar
decision uh the court said uh I I'll
give you a short quote here um that we
do not construe the terms uh shall be
the duty to cherish in our constitution
as a mere statement of aspiration the
language commands commands in no
uncertain terms that the state provideed
an education to all its citizens and
support all public schools now I think
that is you know clearly
false
um article 83 as representative luiki
pointed out has the exact same language
regarding seminaries literature and the
sciences and so on and the Arts um and
no one is at all suggesting that the
legislature is required to fund those
things um public schools are just
mentioned as one of of many items in
that sentence so so anything that
applies to Public Schools would clearly
apply to others the other part of the uh
New Hampshire Supreme Court's
reasoning is the is their interpretation
of the word cherish as requiring
spending and um the way they said that
was they used a an ancient dictionary
and thought that somehow uh the word
cherish means support and support means
spending and stuff like that but but the
word cherish the meaning of it has not
changed from the time that the uh
Constitution was written and as evidence
for that let me uh quote you from uh one
of George Washington's most famous
speeches so George Washington had two
very famous speeches his inaugural
address and his farewell address and his
farewell address in
1796 used the word word cherish three
times and all three of those uh uses of
the word cherish were exactly the same
way we would use the word today um
meaning to you know hold in high esteem
and um support and so on but not has
nothing to do with spending or or paying
for it so so here's um three short
quotes from that
speech um it is of an infinite moment
that you should properly estimate the
immense value of your National Union to
your Collective and individual happiness
you should cherish uh a cordial habitual
and immovable attachment to it so you
know you're cherishing an attachment to
the National Union it has nothing to do
with with taxes or spending or anything
like that later on in the speech he says
um of all the dispositions and habits
which lead to political Prosperity
religion and moral it are indispensable
supports the mere politician equally
with the pious man ought to respect and
cherish them so you you should cherish
uh religion and morality clearly it
didn't mean spending any money on them
and then
finally as a very important source of
strength and security cherish Public
Credit One method of preserving it is to
use it as sparingly as possible so again
he's saying that the the uh credit of
the US government ought to be um
cherished I mean ought ought to be uh
preserved but it has nothing to do with
with specifically with spending in some
way so the word cherish means what it's
always meant um and our constitution
means what it's always meant so
representative liwicki was absolutely
correct on on those points thank you
very much Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you for your testimony
and representative silver do you have a
question I have a question yes it it see
you the question really isn't from a you
know a a a long-term view of the
Claremont decision if we don't like the
Claremont decision and we don't think
the people like the Claremont
decision why don't we just have a cacr
for a constitutional amendment present
to the people to overturn The Claremont
decision instead of resolution which the
court can just you know put up in the
wall in the bathroom or
something well thank you very much
representative but it's not what the
court will do in response to this
resolution the question is what will the
legislature do in terms of its decisions
about education and funding and so on
right what will it put in its budget um
and that kind of thing and so
um some would you know many people would
agree with you that the way to respond
to the court is with a constitutional
amendment but I can tell you I I was um
personally uh very involved in the
passing of our last two Constitutional
Amendments uh the ones about um privacy
and so on and it it is extremely
difficult to pass a constitutional
amendment and so the question is if the
court is acting as in a dictatorial
fashion
is the only
response uh when many many in the
legislature may agree with their uh
conclusions uh to require 2third of vote
of the people and 60% vote of the
legislature and so on to to overcome
that error um or should it simply be
that the legislature together with the
executive um who also have uh re they're
also required by their Oaths to follow
the Constitution and interpret the
Constitution um should just the actions
of those two bodies be sufficient and I
would say the latter there's nothing in
our constitution either the us or the
New Hampshire Constitution that somehow
makes the Judiciary superior to the
other two branches and so if the other
two branches want to conduct their
Affairs in their opinion
constitutionally they should be allowed
sober do you have a
f no I I I I think I understand I
understand the argument I just it would
just seemed to me that a uh no forget it
that's that's enough I raised the issue
Oregan the uh the next to last paragraph
it says uh whereas the legislature
hereby finds declares the amount of
State funding for public education
required by the Constitution
has been remain zero dollars and um so
regardless of whether or what you what
you're a Claremont decision try to make
a cost argument that it had to be
something other than zero do you think a
zero dollar State contribution where
there's no state aid to school districts
is a good idea or or or not and you have
any opinion on what if it's not zero
be um thank you representative for the
question I think it's
somewhat uh irrelevant what I would
think on that subject um
yeah I think it's very unlikely I mean
just politically it's very unlikely the
legislature would ever spend zero on
public
education right thank
you are there any other questions for Mr
Maguire thank you for your testimony
today today thank you Mr
chair and is there anyone else who
hcr3 seeing no one I will close the
hcr3 we do um and that ends our hearings
for
today we are scheduled for hearings
again on Tuesday and Friday of next week
so um I don't know if there's any other
business anybody wants to raise at this
point in
time seeing nothing I hope you all have
a great
weekend and enjoy yourselves take care
bye